ce soir édition spéciale de son économie
l'impact économique de la guerre en
ukraine
[Musique]
des marchés très volatils hausse du
pétrole jusqu'à 105 dollars le baril
faut-il s'attendre à une poussée
inflationniste des prix de l'énergie
l'europe les états unis le canada
annonce des sanctions économiques contre
la russie suite à la frappe militaire
irresponsable et dangereuse de la russie
on impose d'autres sanctions sévères de
ce graphique n a qu en un but digne
quel sera l'effet sur les marchés de
l'économie mondiale avec nous le pdg de
la caisse de dépôt charlie mots vous
êtes maintenant en zone économie
[Musique]
la russie a déclenché hier soir tôt ce
matin en europe une opération militaire
d'envergure en ukraine des frappes en
plusieurs endroits dans le pays les
ukrainiens sont appelés à résister
l'otan a décidé d'envoyer des troupes
dans les pays voisins
bonsoir voici une édition spéciale de
zone économie on va vous parler ce soir
de ce que cette guerre en ukraine signal
sur le plan économique sur le prix du
pétrole le prix du gaz naturel
l'inflation mondiale la croissance
économique mondiale la hausse des taux
d'intérêt est également et on aura tout
au cours de l'émission plusieurs invités
pour nous aider à comprendre les
implications des bombardements russes en
plusieurs endroits en ukraine plusieurs
villes plusieurs régions qui ont été
touchées par les bombardements
et parmi nos invités ce soir le grand
patron de la caisse de dépôt et
placement du québec dévoilait ses
résultats financiers aujourd'hui
andréanne bon soir en soir gerald cette
attaque de la russie a été fermement
condamnées tout au cours de la journée
par la communauté internationale on a eu
les chefs d'états et de gouvernements de
plusieurs pays qui n'ont pas hésité à
dire que cette invasion russe en ukraine
c'était barber que c'était une violation
des droits de la personne des règles
internationales et qu'il y aura
effectivement des conséquences en fait
on a vu tout au long de la journée ces
images saisissantes devant lesquelles la
communauté internationale a voulu lancer
le message aux ukrainiens qui ne seront
pas abandonnés
mais le message s'adressait surtout
aujourd'hui à vladimir poutine lui
disant que ces gestes inacceptables
seront sévèrement punis et que le pays
et la russie s'expose à des sanctions
sans précédent donc des sanctions
d'abord annoncé par joe biden le
président américain dans le cadre d'une
initiative concertée c'est à dire
qu'avec les états unis des pays du g7 et
d'autres pays on va mettre de l'avant
plusieurs mesures notamment on va on
veut empêcher en fait la russie de
brasser des affaires en dollars en euros
en livres en moyenne on veut couper la
russie de l'économie mondiale si vous
voulez
les exportations russes seront
suspendues il ya plusieurs grandes
banques russes donc la deuxième la plus
importante du pays qui est coupé du
système financier occidental
washington va pas s'arrêter là
d'ailleurs on dit qu'on veut empêcher le
pays de s'approvisionner en technologie
l'empêcher de moderniser ses capacités
militaires industriels l'empêcher de se
financer également et ce n'est pas
terminé parce qu'il ya l'europe qui va
annoncer d'autres sanctions à l'issue
d'un sommet d'urgence il y en a eu
également annoncé par le canada
aujourd'hui par exemple les exportations
qui seront également bloqué toute une
série d'individus ciblé également alors
un message très ferme aujourd'hui je
vous invite à écouter justin trudeau joe
biden et boris johnson
ces sanctions ont une grande portée
elles vont entraîner de grand coup aux
élites russes ayant des liens de
complicité et elles vont limiter la
capacité du président poutine à
continuer de financer cette invasion est
justifié
bourgoin sucré on casse
tout
mec
journée stage country get comme prize
in game maximiles
au moins le mec sort mieux tu peux c'est
en tout cas tout cela a créé énormément
de volatilité sur les marchés
aujourd'hui beaucoup de weiss a commencé
très tôt dans la journée sur les places
boursières européennes par exemple qui
sont évidemment les plus touchées dans
ce conflit là on a eu les bourses par
exemple de paris londres francfort d
recul d'à peu près 4 % et à la bourse de
new york la flèche est pas du bon côté
c'est en bout de ligne une hausse de 1,5
pour cent en fait on crut de la séance
le dow jones perdait à peu près 800
points meilleur monde il a au cours de
la séance mais de manière générale c'est
vraiment pour le marché russe où les
pertes ont été les plus sévères
aujourd'hui par exemple pour la devise
russe le rouble qui au cours de la
journée a touché un creux historique
face à la devise américaine finalement
en baisse d'à peu près 3% l'indicé de la
bourse recul d'à peu près 38% avec des
pertes surtout dans le secteur bancaire
beaucoup visées par les sanctions vous
avez par exemple vtb bank et sberbank
des reculs de jusqu'à 40 % et le secteur
gazier 9 35% gazprom en baisse de 30%
parce qu'évidemment un des enjeux c'est
l'énergie on a vu le pétrole bondir
aujourd'hui la avec le brent entre
autres qui a dépassé évidemment les 100
dollars le baril au cours de la séance
et le gaz naturel ce sont les contrats
aux pays-bas en hausse de 52% beaucoup
de pression dans le secteur de l'énergie
en raison de ce conflit absolument
beaucoup beaucoup de pression de
volatilité et on va suivre ça dans les
prochains jours on aura sans doute
beaucoup de volatilité merci andré hahn
alors allez on voit tout de suite donc
le les marchés tout au cours de cette
journée à la clôture donc le tsx a
terminé sur un gain de 18 points hausse
de 92 points pour le dow jones qui
perdait un certain moment de la journée
859 points progression de 436 points
pour le nasdaq donc remontée des valeurs
technologiques en cours de séance et 3
35% et le s&p 500 qui a progressé de 63
points le dollar canadien a baissé dans
la foulée on a vu des investisseurs se
réfugiaient davantage vers des valeurs
sûres comme le dollar américain 78 cents
américains presque 70 centimes d'euro le
prix de l'or qui a frôlé les deux mille
dollars en cours de séance termine à
1900 dollars l'once et finalement la
clôture les cours du pétrole étaient en
progression mais sous la barre des 100
dollars pour le brut wti qui est de
retour à 93 dollars au canada 80 dollars
le baril
[Musique]
alors nous allons analyser tout cela
avec deux invités avec nous ce soir dit
me jean qui est économiste en chef chez
desjardins et jean raby qui est co
directeur général d'audi ses
acquisitions ancien de natixis de
goldman sachs qui a dirigé le bureau de
paris et de moscou monsieur jean
monsieur habib bon soir
alors jimmy jean d'abord que signifie
pour l'économie mondiale ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
c'est un choc sans chocs géopolitiques
majeurs et c'est dans tout comme dans
tout choc de ce genre ces scénarios
d'invasion de conflit militaire ce qu'on
voit c'est vraiment une sorte élections
des prix de l'énergie
particulièrement les prix du gaz naturel
comme ça a été mentionné en europe dont
rhône était déjà dans une situation qui
était extrêmement
corsé avec les prix qui étaient très
élevés donc s'appliquer déjà beaucoup de
pression sur les finances des
consommateurs en zone euro et là on a un
impact additionnel a donc un souci
particulièrement des risques que cela
cause ralentissement prononcé de la
dépense des revenus des ménages
évidemment on l'a vu l'effet sur les
marchés bon ça va créer énormément de
volatilité parce que l'incertitude qui
reliait ça elle sert sud par rapport à
huy les conséquences au niveau des prix
l'énergie mais aussi
en ce qui a trait aux mesures de
représailles qui commencent à être
déployés est ce qu'elle a apporté à
mesure la russie donc les certitudes qui
fait virevolter les marchés et donc
cette incertitude là jean raby elle
annonce quoi exactement faut-il
s'attendre à ce que ce conflit entraîne
un impact économique négatif
internationale importante
plaie il ya je pense que trois
incertitudes il ya la première la nature
de son ont parlé au pakistan raid est ce
que c'est une invasion est ce que c'est
une occupation et je pense que qui
pourrait y avoir vraiment changement de
paradigme si il ya une perception que ça
c'est sandra à d'autres pays limitrophes
de la russie deuxièmement l'impact sur
les chaînes d'approvisionnement
d'énergie les marchés ont réagi
aujourd'hui en anticipant un an
l'approvisionnement mais est-ce que ça
se réalisera et de quelle façon il y
aura des mesures qui pourraient être
mises en oeuvre pour compenser et
troisièmement je pense la grande
incertitude montre que c'est peut-être
ce qui explique aussi le rebond des
marchés en fin de séance aujourd'hui
c'est l'impact que cela peut avoir sur
la remontée des taux d'intérêt la
politique monétaire les différentes
banques centrales aujourd'hui on peut
envisager que la hausse des prix de
l'énergie et la fois source d'inflation
mais aussi peut-être désinflationniste
dans la mesure où ça pourrait ralentir
la croissance économique ok parfait lors
vos maîtres l'équation ensemble si ça
ralentit la croissance économique ça
pourrait ralentir l'inflation jean raby
et ça pourrait ralentir la hausse des
taux d'intérêt
c'est possible moi je pense que c'est
une interrogation qu'il est naturel
d'avoir à ce stade il est très tôt on
est 24 heures depuis lé là le changement
vraiment dans d'environnement on
craignait on se préparait au pire mon
espérer le meilleur laon ville pire
c'est tôt pour le dire mais je pense que
ça peut être une équation dans la tête
de certaines banques centrales
effectivement hockey dit me jean vous
voyez ça comment l'impact de ce qui se
passe parce que on imagine que s'il ya
des perturbations dans
l'approvisionnement gazier dans
l'approvisionnement pétrolier que ça
pourrait créer de l'inflation sur
l'énergie avec un baril de pétrole à 120
ou à 150 dollars comment vous voyez les
choses
donc c'est clair mais face aux neath mme
jeune apprenti c'est lucien jean le
scénario stagflationniste donc ça crée
des pressions négatives sur la
croissance économique soit confiant la
les ménages des entreprises
si vous plus à venir s'expliquer en zone
euro il faut s'attendre à ce qu'il y ait
un recul elle même une contraction des
10 de l'activité économique
est-ce que ça la même chose en amérique
du nord je ne crois pas je pense que
l'entendent échanges commerciaux on est
beaucoup moins exposé à ce qui se passe
a aussi en ukraine les deux ensemble
c'est à peine 0 2 5% de nos notre
commerce international et dans ce
contexte là où est ce qu'on l'a
énormément d'inflation à ce qu on est on
prédire un flic derrière la page
on serait supposément des taux d'intérêt
plus élevés à ce stade si je pense que
les banques centrales en a mais nous
n'en avons gardé le cap sur le haut et
du moins le début mais là sont des tanks
et jean raby est ce que l'europe peut se
passer et on l'expliquait toute la
journée du gaz et du pétrole russes ils
viennent de telle dépendance à l'énergie
russe en ce moment est ce qu'il est
possible
est ce que dit solution pour l'europe
les solutions n'existent qu'à très long
terme aux données du ce de deux
statistiques
l'allemagne 25 % de son bilan
énergétique et le gaz naturel et la très
très grande majorité vient de russie
donc je pense que l'allemagne ne peut
pas se passer du gaz naturel
et c'est pas henry ou france et
centrales nucléaires qui ont été fermées
après coco 6 max à la compagnie va voir
qui va compenser le phénomène et
deuxièmement la russie exporte par voie
maritime environ cinq millions de barils
de pétrole par jour qui peut compenser
cela
pas beaucoup on parle de lettres de
deals iranien qui il rend ramène du
pétrole sur la scène internationale
s'est faite à hauteur de 1.5 à 2
millions de barils par jour on est loin
du compte pour compenser et on sait
qu'aujourd'hui la capacité et le le le
marché du pétrole notamment est très
tendu parce que c'est le reflet d'un
sous-investissement ou d'une très forte
réduction des investissements depuis une
dizaine d'années avec évidemment
l'accent qui a été mis sur les énergies
renouvelables mais avec un décalage
important dans le remplacement dans le
bilan énergétique et sa remplacer les
consignes fused les combustibles
fossiles on sait que c'est un c'est un
défi à très long terme et il n'y a pas
de solution pour ferme dont je pense que
moi c'est juste pas possible que
l'europe se passe du pet du gaz naturel
de russie notamment alors s'il n'est pas
possible ça s'appelle il faut trouver
une solution c'est à dire que les russes
ont certainement un levier exceptionnel
en ayant bâti cette capacité avec les
premières réserves de gaz naturel du
monde mais en même temps je vais vous
laisser continuer dans un instant jean
raby mais en même temps
les européens peuvent tenter de trouver
d'autres sources quand même
momentanément pour tenter de faire
pression sur la russie et la russie son
économie s'appuie en grande partie sur
ses exportations énergétiques
exactement je pense que c'est seul
contrepoids c'est que pour la russie
aussi c'est essentiel de continuer à
exporter des matières premières
notamment dans le domaine des
combustibles fossiles il ya aussi tout
haut mais aussi beaucoup de minéraux qui
sont produits en russie dont la russie
est l'un des principaux producteurs au
monde et qui sont eux mêmes facteurs
importants de production de
2,2 d'outils dans la transition
énergétique par des batteries par des
éoliennes tout toute la chaîne
d'énergies renouvelables repose aussi en
partie sur des minéraux importants dont
la russie est un producteur non
exigeants et le cannabis est un jeu tu
as un équilibre voilà qui vient d'être
fortement atteint par
cet événement exactement dont on ne
mesure pas pleinement les effets en
cascade sur l'économie mondiale jimmy
jean et sur le canada faut-il s'attendre
à un impact économique
ça va surtout être à travers le
mécanisme des prix d'énergie donc on
était des jeunes a cédé à des pressions
très importantes
ça va se poursuivre et ça peut prendre
différentes dimensions parce que qu'on
parle du leader naturel d'explosion des
prix du gaz naturel ç'a un impact sur
les prix par exemple des fertilisants
qui entrent dans la production agricole
or on est déjà dans un contexte où les
prix de l'alimentation sont très élevés
on a beaucoup d'inflation de ce côté là
lorsque ça nous dit c'est que c'est il
va voir la persistance de ce côté là là
ça va prendre plus de temps avant que
les fassions plus par l'honneur à se
modérer étant donné qu on a un nouveau
choc et en plus ce qu'on a vécu depuis
le début cette pandémie la cdppt une
succession de chocs de du côté de
l'offre saas en est un autre donc on va
falloir prendre son mal en patience et
incidemment même si les marques centrale
on s'attend à ce qu'elle continue
d'augmenter ses taux c'est pas en
adoptant des postures beaucoup plus
agressive on règlerait les enjeux donc
l'idée sûr marchés financiers récemment
que la réserve fédérale - la banque du
canada pourrait procéder à des hausses
de 50 points de base on n'y ai jamais
cru parce que effectivement c'est encore
des problèmes d'offre on écartement les
tournées car c'est sur une hausse de
taux d'intérêt rapides d'un demi point
de pourcentage selon vous
absolument avec se passe en ce moment il
a traîné certitudes et on va y aller
avec la méthode prudente de 25 points de
base même si c'est à chaque réunion
auquel aurait seulement pas et on
termine avec vous jean raby en quelques
secondes le marché boursier à partir de
maintenant je présume que c'est un peu
intenable de savoir où on s'envole
beaucoup de volatilité des incertitudes
importantes à à court terme et puis
ensuite savez on est dans une
compo se rattacher ensuite au haut à la
fois l'histoire chaque géopolitiques ont
eu des impacts à court terme et à
moyen et à long terme quand ces chocs
géopolitiques au mans qui commence par
une approche globale mais qui permet une
localement eh bien ça se résorbe et les
fondamentaux économiques votre reportage
de mentionner d'une certaine façon la
russie 7 3 % d'économie mondiale c'est
pas un grand joueur
important d'aller marcher dans les
marchés mondiaux a par son secteur de
l'énergie moi ce que je crée un peu plus
en terminant c'est ce qui peut se passer
ailleurs dans le monde et la chine l'a
clairement sous-entendu
on va parler de là on va revenir avec on
a d'autres invités dans l'émission où on
va revenir justement sur la chine jean
raby merci jimmy jean merci beaucoup
merci à vous
alors cette attaque russe en ukraine
vous inquiète-t-elle c'est la question
qu'on vous pose ce soir
faites-nous connaître votre point de vu
son économie à commercial radio
canada.ca
après la pause de l'instabilité sur les
marchés mondiaux on reçoit le pdg de la
caisse de dépôt et placement du québec
et plus tard le rôle du canada dans
l'approvisionnement en pétrole le rôle
de la chine et de l'allemagne sur le
plan financier
édition spéciale de son économie
consacrée à l'impact économique de la
guerre en ukraine qui a été lancé par la
russie avec nous maintenant charles
aimons le pdg de la caisse de dépôt et
placement du québec pour voir monsieur
montrant soir merci d'être avec nous
présentation des résultats financiers
aujourd'hui de la caisse de dépôt je
vous parle d'abord cela dit de cette
situation de l'ukraine
420 milliards de dollars d'actifs vous
êtes à la tête de l'une des plus grandes
caisses de retraite du monde quand on
voit ce qui se passe présentement qui
déstabilisent l'économie mondiale qui
déstabilise toute une région comment la
caisse de dépôt réagi bah c'est sûr
qu'on travaillait déjà en amont depuis
un bout de temps parce qu'on voyait
certaines situations se développer on
peut pas prévoir exactement certaines
choses mais ces deux de se préparer pour
certaines situations qui ont agi en
conséquence en ce sens là je te rassurer
les québécois là où il ya des impacts
évidemment dans l'économie d'une
situation comme ça mais le portefeuille
est en santé pour ne point de situation
lorsqu'on perd des des millions des
milliards de dollars aujourd'hui mais le
regard
stratégique économique que vous portez
c'est lequel aujourd'hui on fait face
quand même un signe tangible quand même
qui est là qui pourrait donner suite à
un nouvel ordre mondial il faut quand
même pas minimiser ce que c'est en même
temps c'est un conflit qui pour
l'instant régional et on faisait face à
une situation parce qu'on avait poussée
de l'inflation vous inviter en ont parlé
puis des jeunes croissance le kit appelé
à assas et réduire un peu mais c'est
certain qu'avec une hausse du prix du
gaz naturel en europe une hausse du prix
du pétrole on peut exacerber ces deux
facteurs l'eau dans la même direction
l'inflation continue la croissance se
modère davantage l'inflation c'est pas
grave tant que de la croissance est ce
qu'on a vécu en 2021 eu des bons
résultats mais il ya de l'inflation et
plus de croissance ce qui me convenait
un peu plus délicate est ce que la
caisse de dépôt 420 milliards d'actifs
est exposé à ce conflit dont les textes
pose indirectement on peut pas en être
complètement isolé parce que le pétrole
monte le coût de l'énergie le gaz
naturel sain intrants pour les
compagnies c'est certain que l'europe va
être affecté mais regardez aujourd'hui
la réaction sur les marchés il faut pas
toujours foi de tout juste 24 heures les
marchés européens à la baisse mais les
marchés américains après une forte
baisse ont fini à la hausse oui il vous
invite à en parler un petit peu
qu'est-ce qui est derrière ça c'est
qu'on est passé d'une situation complexe
une situation
compliquée la hausse des taux des
banques centrales dans cet environnement
était déjà délicat que l'atterrissage
faire ne pas trop modéré la croissance
tout en contenant l'inflation mais là
qu'est ce qu'on fait et peut-être que le
marché anticipe que les hausses de taux
à certains endroits seront différentes
ses taux comme pronostics mais ces
genres de choses auxquelles on
réfléchisse parce que ça se pourrait que
l'érection soit différente d'un marché à
l'autre une façon locale l'amérique du
nord les états unis l'europe tout se
sera pas affectée parfaitement de la
même façon mais a des impacts quand même
à moyen terme d'une crise comme ça le
globe and mail rapportait aujourd'hui
que vous avez vendu la caisse des
centaines de millions de dollars en
valeur d'actions récemment dans cette
entreprise russe la caisse investit dans
des entreprises russes au 31 décembre
2020 selon la recension du globalement
au total de 36 entreprises russes dans
le portefeuille de la caisse de dépôt
est ce que c'est toujours le cas non en
fait on avait commencé à vendre plus tôt
on n'était pas obligé parce qu'on
respecte toujours les sanctions
canadiennes je tiens à dire mais
néanmoins parce que les sanctions sont
toujours à partir de maintenant par en
avant on a décidé de les vendre on n'a
pas de stratégie d'investir en russie
c'est à dire mes produits je dirais
indiciels parce que évidemment la russie
fait partie du monde alors évidemment
avec des produits des gestionnaires
externes c'est un indice mondial la
russie fait partie mon s'activent déjà
depuis quelques semaines a répliqué les
indices chez nous à l interne sortir de
ces contrôles à extraire la russie il
repas d'exposition pour le québec mais
vous en avez encore des actifs loués et
séminaires mais à une couverture
également là dedans puis je dirais que
rien de majeur pour les dépose mais
gazprom par exemple perd 40% aujourd'hui
est ce que ça fait la caisse de dépôt il
y avait déjà eu des ventes qui avaient
été faites à forts profits sur ces
titres nokia vous avez parlé des
sanctions juste préciser les sanctions
en 2015 canada va imposer des sanctions
en 2015 lors de l'invasion des crimes et
vous déteniez déjà des actifs russes à
ce moment là à travers des produits
indiciels oui donc on n'était pas
légalement obligés de s'en défaire s'en
départir mon le fait néanmoins dans les
dernières semaines dans les dernières
semaines seulement pourquoi avoir
attendu si longtemps légalement on
pouvait c'est un indice quand on a un
marché où est-ce qu'on a un marché
émergent par exemple les indices
comporte les russies alors c'est du
sélect des gestionnaires externes à
l'extérieur de résilier ses contrôles là
c'est un peu plus complexe mais on le
fait pour ne garder ça c'était des
études qui ont été profitables mais dans
le contexte actuel la position de
l'institution ces deux rien à voir en
russie de toute façon il n'y a pas de
stratégie il ya pas de thèse
d'investissement n'y a pas de conviction
à vers ce marché résultat aujourd'hui
rendement on valoir à l'écran de 13,5
pour cent en 2021 actifs nets 420
milliards de dollars par ailleurs les
placements privés 39 2 % le rendement
dans les placements privés les marchés
boursiers 16,2 pour cent les immeubles
les infrastructures 13 6% obligations
revenu fixe une baisse de 0,6 ce pour ça
et une en fait d'abord et avant tout
vous avez largement profité du rebond de
l'année 2021 plus que vos pairs et plus
que l' indice de référence oui pour
l'année très fier en fait c'est des
résultats record au cours des dix
dernières années on a battu lundi ce de
façon significative ces 10 milliards de
valeur ajoutée et les stratégies qu'on a
mis en place dès le milieu de l'année
après corner un diagnostic après le choc
la pandémie l'homme mars avril on est
mis en place des stratégies de repos
seulement marchés boursiers en
immobilier et donc depuis 18 mois on a
beaucoup de valeur ajoutée qui a été
créée cette performance l'homme
satisfait beaucoup de ce point de vue là
vous êtes surtout en grande partie des
centres commerciaux les tours à bureaux
mais on a changé en fait le portefeuille
mobile il
c'est un 180° en 18 mois cent soixante
dix transactions son portefeuille de 65
milliards puis je vous donne une
statistique les secteurs porteurs la
logistique résidentiel l'industriel
commerçants en ligne sont est passé de
28 % du portefeuille immobilier à 42% ce
sont les bons secteurs al'inverse les
secteurs traditionnels en déclin bureau
traditionnel centres commerciaux sont
passés de 45 à 31 % seulement 18 mois on
a donc maintenant plus de secteurs
porteurs que l'inversé soit c'était la
situation à l'opposé à se demander
quelle est la part de risque quand on
comparer ce que nous étaient laquelle je
sais pas quand tout le monde se rappelle
de l'écrasement de 2008 mais la part de
risque aujourd'hui de la caisse de dépôt
on a un portefeuille pour moi
aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient encore plus
en santé mieux positionner un
portefeuille mieux diversion immobilier
on n'a plus d'actifs qui performent donc
d'être concentré à certains endroits
plus qu'une classe d'actifs deviennent
un peu dans un déclin structurel donc de
ce point de vue là je suis très fier du
pivot qui était fait mais c'est pas au
prix d'un risque additionnel mais on a
une construction de portefeuille sont
des assises plus solides et on verra
donc comment ça va se passer en 2022
ça va vite souvent chaque fois qu'on en
compte il ya un événement puis quelques
mois plus tard il sait pas c'est
complètement autre chose alors on verra
merci beaucoup monsieur merci à munich
tout ce soir au revoir
mon collègue mathieu guillon pour parler
de l'effet de la guerre sur nos
entreprises vont soir mathieu en soi
réaction chez bombardier notamment oui
c'est l'une des entreprises qui courent
le plus de risques avec ces sanctions
aux économies qu'on sait qu'à la vente
de jets d'affaires auprès de russes
fortunés et les ventes de jets
d'affaires en russie ça représente
quelque chose comme ça qu'à 6% des
ventes aujourd'hui le pdg eric martel a
déclaré nous continuerons de surveiller
et de suivre toutes les directives et
sanctions mises en place dans
l'intervalle nous ne ferons pas affaire
avec des personnes ou entités
sanctionnées soyaux groupe coopératif
maintenant pourrait avoir des enjeux
d'approvisionnement de fertilisants
parce que il ya des fournisseurs qui se
trouve en ukraine et en russie somme
toute c'est assez limité maintenant
quand on regarde du côté de snc lavalin
on nous dit la sécurité de nos employés
notre première priorité c'est pourquoi
nous suivons de très près l'évolution de
la situation et nous assurerons que les
employés qui habitent ces pays obtienne
un accompagnement qui répondent à leurs
besoins par ailleurs nos activités
commerciales sont très limitées dans ces
pays regardons du côté de couche tard
avec la bannière sur ton qui a 38
magasins qui sont en russie est bien de
ce côté-là on dit c'est difficile à
l'heure actuelle d'avoir une vue
d'ensemble sur les conséquences
potentielles des sanctions
économique et enfin garda world nous
n'anticipons aucun impact significatif
sur nos activités c'est clair et simple
j'ai parlé à plusieurs entreprises
aujourd'hui et qui m'ont toutes dit
court et à moyen terme n'y a pas
vraiment de problème les liens
d'affaires sont somme toute assez à
limiter assez restreint se dit si des
entreprises québécoises ont besoin d
aide le gouvernement du québec sera là
l'entreprise québécoise qui est une
dépendance sur le crâne ou la russie
parce qu'il peut y avoir au hasard
en effet de nombreuses heures vont en
effet la pluie conflit dans mon jeu
retrouvé tout temps de pasqua
et une réaction d'eric girard également
les réactions d'eric girard également
qu' qui parce que ça pourrait susciter
certaines et ça c'est un peu
d'incertitude en vue du budget du québec
qu'on écoute
la russie est un producteur important
d'énergie me serre augmenter prix
d'énergie ça crée de l'inflation que ça
pourrait ralentir l'économie monde
et gérad je voulais vous parler de
vidéotron qui a dit aujourd'hui
solidaires envers la situation actuelle
dans le pays vidéotron annonce qu'elle
retire de maintenant les frais pour les
appels vers l'ukraine faire partir du
canada et ce jusqu'au 31 mars donc on
veut venir aider les familles qui
peuvent être ici au canada et qui
veulent contacter leur père de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique qui sont quand même
nombreux ces familles au canada en effet
merci mathieu avoir
[Musique]
de conflit entre la russie l'ukraine
soulève de nombreux enjeux économiques
des enjeux énergétiques bien sûr mais
aussi pour le monde agricole industriel
le secteur minier avec des impacts au
canada des détails plus tard à
l'émission
et après la pause jusqu'à quel point
l'économie et le pouvoir russe pourrait
être ébranlée par des sanctions
économiques deux experts avec nous dans
trois minutes
ça
édition spéciale de son économie
l'impact économique de la guerre en
ukraine les agriculteurs et les minières
canadiennes pour être profiter des
sanctions contre la russie la puissance
économique russe sera t-elle ébranlé par
les sanctions économiques et les
pétrolières au canada pourrait-elle
remplacer de pétrole russe on vous a
demandé ce soir l'attaqué russe en
ukraine vous inquiète-t-elle à peu près
tout le monde est inquiet sous toutes
sortes de raisons exactement oui bon
lorsqu'on voit ces images c'est sûr que
ce n'est pas rassurant parfois des gens
ont des proches en ukraine ou même en
russie alors oui il ya beaucoup
d'inquiétudes dans les commentaires
qu'on a reçu 1 de la part de stephen
shank qui nous dit j'ai surtout de
l'inquiétude pour la population
ukrainienne
cassandra la montagne elle dit
s'inquiéter du risque d'escaladé elle
dit ça fait vraiment peur cette
situation les alliés doivent se montrer
ferme mais j'ai peur que les sanctions
économiques annoncées n'ai aucune
influence sur poutine jean fontaine lui
nous dit j'ai bien peur que les états
unis et l'europe ne pourront pas se
contenter de sanctions économiques qui
prennent beaucoup de temps à faire effet
malheureusement ce conflit menace de
devenir encore plus violent en espérant
que les ukrainiens trouvent refuge
quelque part quelle tristesse
effectivement et je vous lis un
commentaire qu'on vient tout juste de
recevoir par courriel quelqu'un qui nous
dit jeu david abitbol qui nous disent je
suis très inquiet il travaille en
technologies de l'information est dit la
plupart de son équipe et à kiev il a
passé la nuit suivre ce qui se passait à
s'inquiéter pour les membres de son
équipe qui considèrent comme des
collègues et amis alors voyez ça touche
beaucoup de monde les plusieurs
s'inquiètent de l'impact de ce conflit
sur leurs finances personnelles
également parce qu'on a bien illustré le
lien avec ce conflit et les prix de
l'énergie par exemple qui pourrait
débouler avec une hausse des coûts de
transports aux pour les coûts de
l'alimentation également on a un
commentaire de patrick sauvé qui nous
dit l'économie mondiale est tellement
trop intégré aujourd'hui des
affrontements l'autre bout du monde vont
faire en sorte que rendu à l'été je
devrai choisir entre faire le plein
d'essence et le plein de mon frigo c'est
toute la planète qui va être prise en
otage bon et puis andriole ce conflit-là
soulève quand même plusieurs enjeux
économiques de taille on va ressentir
les effets probablement au canada sur le
plan et j'ai énergétique rappelez-nous
pourquoi l'impact est si grand mais en
fait c'est très simple parce que vous
avez dans ce conflit d'un côté la russie
très grands producteurs et de l'autre
côté l'ukraine qui est un territoire
stratégique pour l'approvisionnement en
hydrocarbures en europe je vais vous
présenter sur un tableau là un petit
rappel des enjeux ou de la position de
ces deux joueurs là c'est à dire que la
russie pour le gaz naturel est le
deuxième exportateur mondial comble 40%
des besoins en europe et le tiers de
toutes les exportations de gaz russe
vers l'europe passe par l'ukraine joueur
important également la russie pour le
secteur pétrolier troisième exportateur
mondial comble 25% des besoins en europe
alors comprenez que ce conflit l'heure
sinon on en vient à perturber les
approvisionnements que ce soit à la
suite de destruction d'équipements en
raison des attaques ou encore par les
sanctions économiques effectivement le
prix du brut pourraient grimper il ya la
bank of america qui dit s'attendre à une
hausse de 20% du prix du baril de
pétrole d'ici l'été et donc aux la
facture de chauffage et hausse du prix
de l'essence effectivement il ce conflit
porte également à la hausse les prix des
céréales à des sommets notamment ça
pourrait avoir un effet positif au
canada exact c'est un enjeu crucial dont
on parle moins mais vous savez que l'ue
la russie et l'ukraine on les surnomme
le grenier à céréales en europe et
effectivement ce sont des joueurs
majeurs l'ukraine par exemple est le
premier producteur mondial de tournesol
pour son huile produits à peu près plus
de la moitié de ce qu'on consomme dans
le monde 4e exportateur de maïs 13 % la
part mondiale mais le grand enjeu c'est
le blé avec l'ukraine et la russie on a
à peu près le quart de toutes les
exportations mondiales de blé la russie
qui est le premier exportateur l'ukraine
le quatrième le canada les etats-unis où
sont une position importante mais
effectivement le prix du blé est déjà en
très forte hausse à la suite de ce
conflit là ça fait grimper les prix de
vente pour les agriculteurs canadiens
qui se demandent s'ils pourront en
exporter davantage si les exportations
russes elles sont bloquées alors pour
l'agriculture ya cet enjeu mais l'enjeu
des fertilisants également jimmy jean
l'évoqué tout à l'heure la russie le
bélarus et le canada sont les plus
grands producteurs mondiaux pour la
potasse si encore une fois les
exportations russes sont bloqués ça
pourrait profiter au canada qui produit
à peu près le tiers de toute la potasse
dans le monde et là on a effleuré le
secteur agricole mais la russie est un
important producteur de métaux également
aluminium nickel cobalt tout ce conflit
mais déjà de la pression sur les prix de
ces métaux l'un est donc le canada
pourrait t'il en profiter c'est la
question qui compte c'est la question
qu'on va poser à nos invités maintenant
merci andre lange a tantôt les
etats-unis l'union européenne le
royaume-uni le canada ont imposé toutes
sortes de sanctions aujourd'hui mais est
ce que ces pénalités auront vraiment un
effet sur la russie et l'effet escompté
on va parler de la puissance russe avec
sylvain odette de hec montréal membre
associé de la chaire en recherche de
gestion du secteur de l'énergie et
justin massy professeur au département
de science politique de l'uqam messieurs
bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur odette d'abord
parlez-nous de l'importance de la
production russe pétrole gaz naturel
mais surtout à savoir est ce que c'est
vraiment décisif cet enjeu énergétique
pour comprendre ce qui se joue autour de
l'ukraine en ce moment
évidemment il ya plusieurs personnes qui
se prononce sur ce conflit là et moi
personnellement soudan énergétique c'est
je remonte à la construction ou la mise
en service du nord stream 2 les russes
n'ont jamais digéré les références
américaines ou début même avant mais de
construire ce gazoduc l'eau les
américains s'étaient opposés a même
initié la construction
finalement les allemands ont écouté le
11 à convaincre un américain il faut le
faire ils ont construit il y près à
l'opération il attendait juste
l'autorisation et là on a vu ils n'ont
enlevé alors qu'il risque de toulon les
américains ne voulaient pas que l'europe
dépend davantage vous avez vu les jeux
tout à l'heure la menace sur les
approvisionnements et qu'il 50% de
gazoducs il aimait qui tenait à tout
prix à ce que
ce second lieu ne soit pas en fonction
il est construit et là il est prêt à
fonctionner mais ils ne veulent pas s'en
vont et sa saga évidemment irrité
beaucoup monsieur coûteux ok donc ce
north stream 2 qui on va le voir dans la
carte l'alleud le fameux pipeline qui va
nous amener à 110 milliards ultime ans
avec les deux pipelines de mètres cubes
de transport de gaz naturel
justin massy la russie fait le plein de
devises étrangères depuis un bon moment
est-ce qu'il est clair dans votre esprit
que moscou préparer cette invasion
depuis très longtemps et étaient très
bien préparées en fait
je crois que oui en fait ce qui est
particulier c'est que l'invasion qu'on
voit se dérouler sous nos yeux je suis
exactement les plans qui avait fuité par
l'administration américaine entendent un
voilier voyez ce qui va se produire on
savait qu'ils avaient accumulé des
devises de rares étrangers américains d
euros également on voyait le déplacement
de troupes militaires sans précédent
près de 200000 trop au nord à l'est et
au sud de l'ukraine où se sont massés
donc corps évasion on suit vraiment plan
de marche le l'espèce de trêve olympique
aussi a été respecté c'est à dire qu'on
l'a entendu la famille olympique avant
de mener l'évasion ça aussi ça avait été
prévu et la recherche de prétexte au
pôle oublie ici donc la reconnaissance
des deux républiques séparatistes alès 2
c'était pour essayer de trouver une
raison pour laquelle justifier cette
invasion souhaitant que des forces
ukrainienne frappent la russie pour
justifier cette intervention l'a
finalement les troupes ukraine ont été
assez disciplinés mais évidemment
poutine avait déjà fait pris sa décision
pour envahir le plie donc oui on l'a vu
venir et même les sanctions et que les
mecs là qui sont menacées qui commencent
à être mises en place par l'occident ont
aussi été de plus depuis des mois en
fait qu'il y aurait des conséquences et
ça aussi vladimir poutine de salé avant
de décider l'invasion on peut regarder
sont hélas le canada donc qui annonce la
suspension de l'émission de permis
d'exportation vers la russie sarr pas un
gros c'est un gros effet bien sûr là
parce que c'est quand même pas des
grands partenaires commerciaux
mais les 27 de l'union européenne le
royaume-uni les etats-unis
sévissent également avec différentes
sanctions économiques on a parlé de
l'énergie
sylvain odette on a parlé donc de ses
devises justin massy est ce que vous
diriez que la russie a les reins solides
des réserves une capacité pour affronter
ces sanctions économiques s'il 20 euros
dit
il
c'est sûr qu'ils peuvent vivre comme on
le dit car ils peuvent ils peuvent ils
peuvent sourire ne peut encore
quelques jours quelques jours quelques
semaines quelques mois surtout avec
l'appui de la chine comme on l'a
mentionné mais moi personnellement je
pense que je lis dit la dernière fois
qu'on avait parlé de ce conflit là je
passe tous ne participent pas au coeur
du jour où il participe au coeur qu'il
préparait comme vous l'avez dit et puis
demain il ya des gagnants et des
perdants mais les gars alliance ça va
être les producteurs de gaz nord
américain et qui vont créer ils ont déjà
commencé
si vous soulevez la suite et ils ont
commencé à réactiver les projets
d'exportation de gaz naturel liquéfié et
il faut signer des contrats long terme
avec ce et donc les contrôles internes
qui gagnent pas ils gagnent des places
est carrément des contrats qui pourrait
passer par un autre hymne veut donc le
tout cette perte d'argent là qui quand
même très important à mon avis un moment
donné
monsieur poutine va vouloir mais écoutez
si vous voulez que je sorte s'oublie qu
on calme le jeu pouvez-vous au moins me
permette de utiliser le nom windows et
da le kg au personnel mais je pense que
par sept jeunes lot
il ya eu hier il y avait plus
d'arguments ils disent bon et gardez moi
je suis là je suis où je pense qu'il
s'attend pas à ce que les on fasse la
guerre vers man sur le terrain ouais
mais il y avait un seul capable de dire
là vous aurez payé par exemple ils
perdent toute la ligne e dire écoutez
est-ce que permettez-moi de signe un
contrat avec hbo pour l'honneur sur deux
est au lieu d'aller chercher du gaz
naturel qui vient des états unis donc
c'est notre hymne de dorian cela trahit
ses vedettes le nord stream 2 selon
votre analyse devient central pour la
suite des choses
selon moi oui parce que évidemment c'est
ça va être ça sera un apport de capitaux
étrangers très important et puis là il
est bloqué par les américains est il
maintenant il est bloqué et là il veut
ce qu'il veut aller chercher
des changes peut-être qui va
éventuellement dangereuse pendant ces
mois quatre mois c'est un petit bobo
loire avait des négociations m face
confie la vie ok moi les conditions
c'est ça parce qu'avant ce faire il a
pas beaucoup de cadres dans son jeu
justement si on exclut pour l'instant la
possibilité de sortir la russie de ce
qu'on appelle le réseau swift ce système
des changes
d'information interbancaire qui réunit
11 mai l'établissement financier et qui
facilite comme ça les virements
internationaux sécurisé
compte tenu qu'on n'exclut pas la russie
sur le plan financier sur le plan
économique est ce que dans le fond la
russie les sanctions qu'on applique à la
russie ne rompt pas beaucoup d'effet sur
la russie
je pense qu'elles vont avoir un effet
important sur l'économie russe mais pas
simplement décollée difficile
européennes mondiales de voir canadien
évidemment mais pas au point de changer
de comportement l'idée ça c'est évident
les sanctions que les mixer pour la
punir la russie ce n'est pas pour
empêcher son comportement ou la faire
retirer ses troupes de l'évasion qui
s'amorce à peine on est vraiment au
début de l'évasion ça va se poursuivre
dans le tour plusieurs jours encore je
ne crois pas que ce sera suffisant pour
changer le comportement parce que la
volonté russe de contrôle et l'ukraine
dépasse de loin les coups qu'on peut
plus infliger incluant peut-être la
saisie d'avoirs de liga reproche donc
dans la garde rapprochée de poutine
incluant elle n'est pas qu'économique
que ça peut avoir sur la société auto
russe alla avec le seul bémol je dirais
la vue les manifestations qui ont lieu
présentement la russie qui pourrait par
contre a mené un certain soulèvement
populaire une grogne populaire australie
la russie peut compter quand même sur
une forme d'appui parfois clair parfois
tacite la du brésil de l'inde l'afrique
du sud et principalement de la chine
absolument et c'est une voie de sortie
incontournable la situation dans lequel
on vit aujourd'hui en 2022 le passé de
2014 ou même il ya quelques années
auparavant la chine étant une énorme
économie est capable de compenser on le
veuille au fait il ya quelques jours
seulement avec leur liste s de pacte de
non-agression concis à la prise d'un
chinois et russes en dedans mais
essentiellement nous allons reconnaître
bogut velléités pour l'ukraine et la
russie en échange rossi reconnaître
débilité et un jour chinoise vis-à-vis
de taiwan et on va faire des accords
commerciaux encore plus grand soutien
dans la guerre un soutien chinois
d'ailleurs qui dure depuis 2000 14 de
plus que les premières sanctions ont été
émises avec l'annexion de la crimée à
l'époque donc la chine continue de
soutenir le système financier banquiers
reçu absolument un mot en terminant
monsieur odette ya jason kenny le
premier ministe d'alberta qui dit qu'il
espère profiter de cette situation pour
exporter davantage d'hydrocarbures
albertain est remplacé je vous vois
sourire le pétrole russe advenant qui en
a moins dans le marché est-ce que c'est
réaliste
personnellement je pense pas je pense
que le ptra et le russe prête à
remplacer par d'autres sources de
pétrole dans le monde je pense pas que
le canadien est bien positionné pour
jouer ce rôle là bon on sait qu'il ya
peu d'accès à départ on ne savait pas
l'abandon du projet de pipeline donc
personnellement je pense que plus les
jours de fournisseurs qui vont
uniquement profiter que davantage de
canal ok merci beaucoup vous êtes c'est
passionnant justin massylvain odette
merci d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui
justement on va se rendre en alberta
tout de suite après la peau sous le
gouvernement annonçait son budget
imaginer un surplus budgétaire l'alberta
ce qui veut donc remplacer le pétrole
russe
non
[Musique]
la guerre en ukraine a fait grimper les
prix de l'énergie aujourd'hui ça
pourrait d'une certaine façon profiter
au canada et à l'alberta en particulier
ordre et 9e à moncton de premier
ministre jason kenney ne se gênent pas
d'ailleurs pour rappeler que l'albertain
est une source stable d'énergie
ce n'est pas la première fois que le
premier ministre john kani vendre le
pétrole albertain qui est plus propre et
plus éthique selon lui que celui qui est
produit dans certains pays autoritaires
comme la russie et l'arabie saoudite
mais l'italie encore plus loin hier soit
alors que commençait l'invasion russe de
l'ukraine en appelant à un embargo un
embargo pardon sur toutes les
exportations de pétrole et de gaz
naturel russe a été saluée par certains
comme une sanction économique qui
pourrait avoir un effet mais d'autres y
ont vu une mesure qui était plutôt
opportuniste c'est vrai que l'alberta
produit beaucoup de pétrole et de gaz et
que si c'était il y en avait moins en
russie qu'on en a acheté moi ça pourrait
bénéficier à la province mais certains
ont trouvé que c'était trop tôt là et
que c'était vraiment une mesure
opportuniste faut quand même mentionné
que le premier ministre dans son
gazouillis a quand même appelé la
communauté danseurs à défendre l'ukraine
a condamné l'invasion russe de l'ukraine
mais il a toutefois mentionné que la
faiblesse invite l'agression ce qui peut
être considéré par certains comme une
critique des pays occidentaux face à la
russie par ailleurs c'était jour de
budget en alberta audrey aujourd'hui on
constate quand même un redressement très
important de la situation financière
grâce au pétrole notamment en parle même
de surplus budgétaires
imaginez on passe d'un déficit projeté
l'an dernier de 18 milliards de dollars
à un surplus de 500 millions cette année
donc tout un revirement il s'est presque
entièrement due à l'explosion des
redevances pétrolières dont l'alberta
dépend énormément et ils ont été
multipliés par six au cours de la
dernière année donc c'est vraiment les
montagnes russes albertaine qui se
poursuivent ça permet d'équilibrer le
budget pour la première fois en huit ans
et de ne pas non plus imposer de
compression au budget des différents
ministères ont réinvesti en santé et en
éducation notamment mais plusieurs
déplorent le fait qu'il n'y a presque
aucune mesure dans ce budget pour aider
les familles albertaine à faire face à
l'inflation pourrait ne venir singh
audrey 9e merci beaucoup
oui merci au revoir
[Musique]
après la pause la demande pour
l'électricité est aussi en forte hausse
à profite largement à hydro québec
[Musique]
son spécial de zones économiques
consacré à la guerre en ukraine mais
deux autres nouvelles dans l'actualité
économique aujourd'hui hydro québec a
annoncé des profits records pour 2021
grâce à la force de la reprise
économique la société d'état a
enregistré un bénéfice net de 3
milliards 546 millions de dollars pour
l'ensemble de l'exercice c'est une
hausse de 55% et hydro va verser un
dividende record de deux milliards 673
millions au gouvernement du québec en
plus des ventes record d'électricité au
québec hydro québec a profité d'une
hausse des prix à l'exportation
et santé canada approuve le vaccin
développé par l'entreprise québécoise
medicago il s'agit du premier vaccin
contre la copie de développer au canada
mais aussi le premier à utiliser une
technologie de production sur plante
lors des essais cliniques le vaccin
s'est avéré efficace à 100% contre les
formes graves de la crau vide santé
canada recommande l'administration des
deux doses à 21 jours d'intervalle
le vaccin est approuvé pour les adultes
de 18 à 64 ans
andréanne le pdg de la caisse de dépôt
s'inquiète de l'inflation qui sera
alimenté par le conflit entre la russie
et l'ukraine et plusieurs de nos invités
lors de cette émission spéciale ont mis
de l'avant le fait que l'enjeu
énergétique est un enjeu majeur dans ce
conflit là étant donné l'importance de
la russie 1 à titre de producteur de gaz
naturel et la dépendance de l'europe
face au gaz russe et cette crête
effectivement que le ca fait grimper les
prix de l'énergie dans un contexte où ce
conflit pourrait réduire la croissance
économique de l'europe d'abord mais
est-ce que ça aura un impact encore plus
large est ce qu'on risque de se
retrouver dans une situation de
stagflation c'est une petite crainte
effectivement pour le pdg de la caisse
de dépôt c'est certain qu'avec une
hausse du prix du gaz naturel en europe
une hausse du prix du pétrole on peut
exacerber ces deux facteurs l'eau dans
la même direction l'inflation continue
la croissance se modère davantage
l'inflation c'est pas grave tant que de
la croissance est ce qu'on a vécu en
2021 eu des bons résultats mais c'est de
l'inflation et plus de croissance ça
c'est une combinaison peut plus délicate
très intéressant par ailleurs c'est un
conflit d impact aussi sur l'industrie
du sport mais on risque de voir de plus
en plus d'associations sportives tenté
de se mêler de ce qui se passe en ce
moment où du moins prendre des décisions
en fonction de ce conflit là entre
autres l'union des associations
européennes de football quitté une
réunion demain devait savoir que la
finale de la ligue des champions est
toujours prévue pour se tenir à
saint-pétersbourg le 28 mai prochain en
russie c'est très délicat les
associations sportives de manière
générale se vante d'être apolitique
est-ce qu'on peut tenir une finale comme
ça très suivie ces 400 millions que les
spectateurs habituellement dans un pays
qui viennent faire l'évasion d'un autre
plusieurs autres matchs sportifs très
important le des coupes du monde de ski
de surf des neiges la formule 1 le grand
prix de sotchi en septembre prochain
qu'est ce qui va arriver avec tout ça
c'est beaucoup d'argent gerald les
décisions de s'en viennent merci
beaucoup andréanne je vous en prie merci
pour cette émission spéciale merci à nos
invités également merci à vous à la
maison avoir été bien attentifs dans un
instant une autre édition spéciale 24,60
sûr ici rdi bonne soirée à domaine
[Musique]
jeudi 24 février ce soir une émission
spéciale de 24,60
[Musique]
il place taksim
facilitateur with the nikkei a fini ce
temps facebook le royalisme vih-sida
openskies il s'est quand même rossi
victime jour non si
c'est quelque chose de délirant
d'impensable d' injustifiée vous savez
mes parents sont là bas ma mère des
mails va voir 85 ans qu'elle doit partir
événements de cette nuit sont un
tournant et des soeurs pour
trois années ce qui lui apporte aux
trotskistes nul à cet acte de guerre
nous répondrons sans faiblesse on le
prend pas tout ça aux joueurs
de décider
[Musique]
une première nuit d'enfer un cauchemar
qui ne fait que commencer en ukraine
avec les témoignages que vous venez
d'entendre dans nos machette madame
monsieur bonsoir bible à 24,60 une
émission spéciale consacrée à cette
guerre en ukraine une guerre aux portes
de l'europe une guerre qui va déjà au
delà de ce qu'on appréhendait la
capitale ukrainienne kiev est encerclée
mais menacés au terme d'une première
journée de phase iib virus
l'opération a fait jusqu'ici
137 morts selon le président ukrainien
et linz qui se seraient des soldats une
centaine de milliers de personnes
désespérées ont quitté leurs foyers et
des milliers d'autres ont quitté le pays
ou veuille le quitter la réponse de
l'occident n'a pas tardé mais est-elle à
la hauteur des appréhensions des
inquiétudes un train de nouvelles
sanctions a été annoncée pour tenter de
faire mal à la russie quitte à la faire
reculer mais au cours des deux
prochaines heures nous tenterons de
comprendre l'impact politique économique
et humanitaire de ce nouveau front sur
le continent européen
tout d'abord nous joignons nos
correspondantes sur le terrain qui
depuis plus de plusieurs jours mais
encore depuis 24 heures sont sans
relâche pour nous informer d'un marin
altéré sco rostom sur le donne en russie
bonsoir tamara merci encore des clés
avec nous et marie ève bédard du côté
ukrainien à kiev bonsoir de marie-eve
encore une fois bonsoir à toutes les
deux je commençais avec vous marier
parce que on a vu des combats qui se
sont rapprochés de la capitale président
ukrainien convient de voir en manchette
encore qui se désole que l'actuel soit
laissé seul face à l'armée russe et qui
parle d'un rideau de fer déjà qu'ils qui
tombe sur eux
c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'il a dit c'est
que ce qu'on entendait depuis avant
l'aube aujourd'hui c'est le bruit non
seulement des explosions des tirs mais
surtout de ce rideau de fer qui est en
train de retomber et qu'il fallait faire
en sorte que le rideau de fer s'affaisse
sur les russes sur la russie pour les
séparer du reste du monde civilisé et
non sur l'ukraine mais vous l'avez dit
dans sa dernière adresse à la population
ukrainienne où il a annoncé 137 morts
pour la journée d'aujourd'hui
il a dit se sentir bien seul au front au
combat il a multiplié les appels aux
dirigeants des pays occidentaux 27 entre
autres pour leur demander si l'ukraine
pourrait se joindre à l'otan si des pays
allait se joindre à la mi-août crânienne
pour combattre les forces russes et il
est seul at il dit tout le monde a peur
quand je pose la question on a peur
personne n'essaie de s'avancer le
président vladimir poutine a dit vouloir
parler je n'ai pas peur de lui parler de
quoi que ce soit mais tous les autres
ont peur donc ça c'est un message le
dernier qu'il a adressé à la population
ukrainienne il a aussi rendu hommage aux
gens qui se sont battus aujourd'hui
jusqu'au bout qui ont tout donné y
compris leur ville a pris dans un moment
très remplie d'émotion un moment de
silence pour entre autres des
gardes-frontières de lille 2 min qui ont
tous péri en tentant de repousser une
offensive russe pour l'instant la nuit
et les calmes mais je vous dirais que en
fin de journée les angoisses de nouveau
augmenté d'un cran parce que les rumeurs
courraient qu une fois de plus les
attaques seraient importantes surtout
sur la capitale qu'on essaierait de
venir chercher les principaux sites du
goût en nommant les ministères la
présidence le parlement aussi il a
prévenu qu'il fallait faire très
attention à la désinformation qui
circule en ce moment en disant ukrainien
on tente de vous faire croire que j'ai
fui la capitale que je ne suis plus à
kiev mais je vous assure que j'y suis et
que nous avons toujours la situation
entre les mains je ne vais nulle part on
écoute je remettrai ma brosse temps
overbooké raquette bouillie hiruta
direct facebook law is a lie
puisque ice in the rain prochain vit-il
zone en tweed marché national jordanien
chez pias avis ce n'est pas
rien
et marie-eve poutine avait pourtant
permis de cibler que les sites
militaires et finalement les civils non
plus ne sont pas épargnés on a vu des
images qu'il illustrait bien
voir plusieurs des installations
militaires ont été visés selon la russie
ce sont plus de 80 base piste aérienne
aussi qui ont été rendus hors service
par les combats au cours de la journée
ils se sont emparés de la zone
d'exclusion de tchernobyl ça c'est une
information qui est confirmée à la fois
par le gouvernement ukrainien et par le
gouvernement russe là où il ya eu cette
catastrophe écologique cet accident
nucléaire en 1986 alors on craint pour
l'état de cette zone d'exclusion parce
qu'il ya encore du déchet nucléaire ça
peut craindre des dégâts encore plus
importants maintenant mais sinon on y va
de contre affirmations et d'affirmation
les russes ont combattu très fortement
dans l'est et au sud du pays ils ont été
repoussés tantôt par les ukrainiens
ensuite les russes ont repris du terrain
mais tout ça ne pas épargner la
population civile c'est vrai on l'a vu à
kharkhiv entre autres il ya un édifice
où habitaient des gens où il ya eu une
explosion
ailleurs aussi plusieurs blessés des
dizaines et des dizaines on n'a toujours
pas fini le décompte et des morts dont
certains enfants dans ces incendies on
tente d'évacuer la région en milieu
d'après-midi les évacuations organisée
par le gouvernement ont commencé autour
de 14h15 heure par autobus par train on
a dit maintenir tous les trajets des
trains sauf dans les endroits où
vraiment c'était impossible il fallait
faire trop d'efforts pour dérouter les
liens ferroviaires donc on a cherché à
faire partir les gens de cette région
avec l'imposition de cette loi martiale
ça facilite mais on a aussi reproché au
gouvernement de la russie de faire la
sourde oreille aux appels qui ont été
envoyés par le gouvernement ukrainien
pour établir un corridor sécuritaire
pour que ces évacuations là puisse se
faire dans le calme vous parliez de ces
gens qui se réfugient dans le métro ça
je vous dirais qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
peu le privilège des gens qui habitent
les grandes villes d'avoir ces endroits
sous terre pour pouvoir passer la nuit
ils sont massés dans toutes les stations
de métro ici à kiev mais à kharkhiv
aussi sans savoir ce que la nuit leurs
réserves il reste encore plusieurs
heures avant de voir si une opération
massive va être lancée sur la capitale
kiev mais c'est clairement ce qu'on
redoute le plus souvent ce mot on les
écoute
les nautitech investor me le dise des
choses étaient beaucoup mieux
m
mo
les ukrainiens s'étaient préparés ils
ont gardé leur sang froid et les choses
se font dans l'ordre aujourd'hui mais
cette peur dans cette jeune fille parle
elle est bien présente on la sent
partout il ya cette angoisse et
l'incertitude de ce qui vient demain des
gens n'imaginaient pas l'ampleur de la
tâche qui est en train de se dérouler en
ce moment alors on craint que ça puisse
de plus en plus dégénéré ils ont
commencé à s'armer les ukrainiens le
gouvernement distribue maintenant
ouvertement à tous ceux qui le
souhaitent des armes pour pouvoir
défendre les villes les place un peu
partout mais avec la mobilisation
générale je crois qu'on interdit aux
jeunes hommes de 16 ou 18 ans de rester
au pays de ne pas de ne pas s'en aller
si on leur interdit de quitter ce à dire
que ceux qui s'étaient inscrits dans
cette mobilisation
on avait changé la loi en janvier pour
permettre ce type de choses ça inclut
aussi les femmes pour l'instant ils sont
exclus de cet ordre de mobilisation
générale mais on avait rappelé les
réservistes régulier hier et aujourd'hui
c'est tous ceux qui ont collaboré à ses
entraînements des forces de défense
territoriale qui vont être appelés en
service là où ils peuvent être utiles
beaucoup de courage merci beaucoup
marie-eve soyez prudents merci beaucoup
beaucoup on est tous avec vous au revoir
mois
tamara intéresse qu bonsoir les
autorités russes afin maintenant
qu'elles ont rempli avec succès leur
mission que tous les objectifs ont fixé
au 1er jour de l'invasion c'est un
succès
premier jour de combien de jours c'est
ça la question qui se pose ici
j'écoutais marie-eve puis c'est un peu
absurde d'être si près mais de se sentir
si loin parce que nous on est du côté
d'où toute cette artillerie est lancé
mais on n'en voit pas les conséquences
et les ententes comme ça c'est c'est ce
réel sur elle aussi parce que ce qu'on
diffusait la télévision ici le russe
moyen qui se fit comme source
d'information à la télévision d'état n'a
pas les témoignages qu'on vient
d'entendre n'a pas les
le bilan des victimes via sûrement des
soldats russes qui sont morts
aujourd'hui et c'est pas la télévision
la télévision d'état qui qui va leur
apporter ici ce qu'on rapporte c'est
toujours que c'est une mission
d'autodéfense de style et seuls deux
ukrainiens se rendent ils seront bien
traités il ya une manipulation très
certainement de ce qui est encore décrit
comme une intervention qui était
nécessaire
qui était une question de vie ou de mort
pour la pour la survie du peuple russe
et les médias sont très limités dans ce
qu'ils peuvent diffuser on a tous reçu
sur le téléphone ce matin des
avertissements qui s'appelle censure
militaire et qui prévient les
journalistes qu'ils doivent se limiter à
diffuser des informations qui ont été
corroborées au fournis par le ministère
de la défense c'est sous peine d'amendé
ou de france administrative qui dans le
cas des journalistes étrangers peuvent
être peuvent mener à une expulsion donc
un contrôle de l'information alors qu'on
est en train de parler
du plus grand conflit en europe depuis
la 2 mondial donc ce n'est pas la seule
source d'information évidemment en
russie mais il ya des gens qui sont
adeptes de la télévision d'état et de la
propagande qui est à son maximum en ce
moment et puis donc vous êtes quand même
chanceux de pouvoir quand même encore
nous parler
m exactement l'analyse que vous faites
de la situation en contraste avec ce que
maya vie du côté de l'écran cela dit à
côtoyer les gens près de la frontière où
vous êtes ils témoignent de quoi ces
gens là quelle est l'ambiance qui règne
dans cette région en particulier dans
les villes frontalières mais surtout si
à rostov sur le don et quand il ya eu la
guerre dans basse vallée s'est jamais
terminée mais au plus fort des combats a
eu beaucoup de réfugiés qui sont venus
ici encore une vague qu'on a encore à
laquelle on a assisté il ya un sentiment
de loyauté par rapport à la population
pro-russe qui habitait dans ses bastions
donc il ya un soutien pour cette pour
cette invasion mais si elles s'étaient
limitées au territoire du donbass je
pense qu'il ya un soutien
on sent aujourd'hui beaucoup de stupeur
mais mes yeux deux camps comme je vous
dis supiot qui adhèrent au narratif du
gouvernement comme quoi l'ukraine est un
ennemi direct
il voit une invasion qui était
nécessaire et je vous donne un
échantillon des témoignages qu'on a pu
récolter aujourd'hui entre la le soutien
et la stupeur on écoute
vous n'aimez pas de l'outaouais
politique doit trimer nos sites yasmine
chapitre passtime et sodabo dit terry
short nuit et j'avoue je suis mon resto
médias
quand un joueur comme chef choqué
absolument c'est pas
nous resterons le panama et kenya
6/2 1/6 40 cette année
caracas la compétition marc gène yannick
agnel le jeu au même choqué
ce poste
et tamara en russie des citoyens ont
manifesté pour dénoncer
cette agression mais
avec de graves conséquences pour eux
au pire il d'être arrêté c'est
exactement ce qui est arrivé il ya eu
des grandes manifestations à moscou à
saint-pétersbourg avec un terrain bon
dans les grandes villes de russie
aussitôt sorti aussi tout menotté on
raconte on dénombre 1800 arrestation ça
c'est le minimum c'est les derniers
chiffres que j'ai vu en que pas de
tolérance pour les gens qui s'opposent à
cette guerre mais on sent on sent chez
les russes
le sentiment le besoin de dire qu'on ne
représente pas comme vous l'avez entendu
que la présidence ne représente pas le
peuple et donc on semble beaucoup
d'inquiétude pour la suite des choses on
sait pas où ça va s'arrêter on sait pas
jusqu'où vont aller les conséquences
déjà les sanctions et je sais vous allez
en parler en profondeur dans votre
émission mais les clés le risque l'union
européenne refuse d'accorder des visas à
des russes la grande bretagne qui a déjà
dit qu'elle allait sanctionner aeroflot
qui est le transporteur il ya des
sanctions le rouble qui est à son plus
bas niveau de l'histoire cdc des
conséquences directes sur la population
russe une vague de haine aussi il ya eu
15 alerte à la bombe aujourd'hui à
moscou
c'est ce qui s'en vient qui fait peur à
la population qui reste qu'ils très
certainement ça va de plus en plus isolé
effectivement au cours de l'émission va
analyser l'impact de ces sanctions qui
tendent à viser l'élite ruche les
oligarques les banques les milieux
d'affaires et
mais on va voir si pour certains
analystes c'est assez ou pas parce que
ce qu'on dit c'est que depuis 48 heures
on avait annoncé des sanctions et
regardez ce qui arrive poutine est allé
de l'avant avec son intention de
conquérir l'ukraine à leurs camarades
ont su réaliser mon village de quelque
chose
c'est lille ni sanction c'est plus pour
prévenir ces pour punir à ce stade ci il
le rencontrer les gens d'affaires
monsieur vladimir poutine on l'a vu
aujourd'hui à la télévision c'est encore
une fois que mise en scène et il leur a
dit c'était nécessaire alors est ce que
ces gens là sont prêts à accepter les
conséquences des actions du président ça
reste à voir alors bon courage à vous
aussi un immense merci d'être sur le
terrain pour nous tamara on se reparle
au cours des prochaines heures et à mon
caméraman à lui et à toute l'équipe puis
on espère qu'on peut prendre un petit
peu de rue peel depuis 24 heures de télé
sans relâche merci beaucoup d'amants au
revoir au retour que veut réellement
vladimir poutine jusqu'où ira-t-il c'est
la question qu'on va se poser au cours
des deux prochaines heures est avec nous
nous avons tous les mêmes besoins
seul vous rire se sentir en sécurité
s'informer à la meilleure source
fiable et pertinente
choisissez ici r d est essentielle quoi
qu'il arrive
le président joe biden prononce son
premier discours sur l'état de l'union
retrouver anne marie dussault pour une
émission spéciale mardi dès 20h55
hier 10 quoi qu'il arrive
aux assurances vous semble trop cher
venez les magazines et sur clay cassure
points comme assurance habitation
automobile entreprise vie obtenait les
meilleurs prix pour tous vos besoins
d'assurance économiser avec clic assure
points comme le secret de tous les
grands chefs repose sur la façon dont
ils aiguisent leurs couteaux
imaginez un couteau très utilisé mais
qui n'a pas à être constamment et ise
c'est maintenant possible
voici l'ensemble de couteau nutri bray
de granit stone enduit de lentilles
adhérents granit sonde est conçu en
acier inoxydable un des matériaux des
plus résistantes y soit pour des coupes
encore plus précise tous peuvent
maintenant coupé tranché et émincer
comme de vrais pros plus inconfortable
très précis pensais qu'il fallait un
coup pour avoir de tels résultats
c'est prendre un couteau et broyage une
poignée de caoutchouc ergonomique permet
un meilleur contrôle et une précision
accrue pour couper des salades ou encore
la viande congelée et obtenir des
tranches finement coupées des aliments
se détache facilement grâce à un
revêtement anti à teyran où ils peuvent
être déposés au lave vaisselle des
coupes très précises 46 pourquoi payer
trop cher aujourd'hui
obtenez l'ensemble de six couteaux nutri
blé pour seulement rentable de l'art 95
vous recevrez le couteau santoku pour
trancher les fruits et émincez les
oignons un couteau pour obtenir deux
fils tranche de réguler ou de
charcuterie le couteau dentelé pour
trancher de pain plus facilement le
couteau du chef ultra léger avec surface
réduite pour moins de frictions le
couteau tout usage polyvalent pour ma
cuisine ou autres otages et le couteau a
épluché idéal pour trancher et petit des
petits fruits 29 $ 95 un remarquable
bien si vous commandez maintenant nous
livrerons votre commande gratuitement
obtenir ensemble nutri blocs de granit
stone vous n'aurez plus jamais à acheter
votre couteau a trait au numéro affiché
à l'écran ou commandez en ligne a acheté
lutherie bray points c'est à pour
obtenir votre ensemble des couteaux
nutri blanc pour 29 dollars 96 il a
livraison est gratuite
comment dès maintenant
vos gencives saigne minutes ça pourrait
être un signe de gingivite laurence
bouche listerine contient des huiles
essentielles anti bactérienne qui tue
jusqu'à 99,9 pour cent des germes et
combat la plaque et la gingivite
listerine fiable depuis plusieurs
générations 125 ans de pouvoir
antibactérien
[Musique]
les laurentides notre décor votre
scénario hiver
[Musique]
ça va avoir un impact sur la russie si
sanction pas juste par le canada mais
par les pays européens les etats-unis la
grande-bretagne
on le prend pas
on n'accepte pas que vladimir poutine
choisissent de faire fi de bafouer
complètement les règles qui nous ont
gardés
sain et sauf et stable en tant que monde
mais
les sanctions porté à la russie seront à
la hauteur de l'agression dont elle se
rend coupable sur le plan militaire et
économique autant que dans le domaine de
l'énergie nous serons sans faiblesse
les sanctions ont-elles vraiment un
effet pour dissuader poutine le freiner
complètement elma fois sauvé les
ukrainiens de cette agression on
poursuit avec nos invités qui sont avec
nous tout au long de l'émission pour
mieux analyser la situation de ce jour 1
et la suite de mener car elle titulaire
de la chaire d'études ukrainienne à
l'université d'ottawa bonsoir de mieux
car elle mais c'est encore l'été avec
nous frédéric mayrand directeur
scientifique du cérium et professeur de
sciences politiques à l'université de
montréal bonsoir frédéric mérand merci
encore et ekaterina puisque ou nouveau
professeur au département de science
politique de l'université de montréal
également chercheuse au ceri un
spécialiste de la russie bonsoir madame
puisque novembre alors premier tour avec
vous de votre réaction de votre
peut-être votre stupéfaction devant les
récents événements sont ils plus grave
que ce que vous aviez appréhender madame
puisqu'une aura beaucoup plus grave
c'est un choc total a
jeté extrêmement inquiète par la
situation depuis des mois par contre je
pensais que la sagesse humaine l emporte
non on a raté la possibilité de
négociations
malheureusement on n'a pas offert des
garanties de sécurité à l'ukraine de la
protection suffisante à l'ukraine et
les situations et sap est absolument
tragique mais parce qu en effet frédéric
mayrand monsieur le président c'est lui
qui vient de déclarer qu'il se sent bien
seul à kiev malgré toutes ces sanctions
annoncées pour pouvait revenir au cours
de l'émission sur leurs valeurs leurs
effets réels mais je dis que mara il se
sent bien seul est ce que c'est ce qu'il
évoque qu'il aurait dû avoir un appui
plus concret même de la communauté
européenne de l'otan des alliés non je
ne crois pas que l'ukraine soit seul ni
ses gouvernants en fait les alliés n'ont
jamais été aussi unis dans leur
dénonciation des attaques de la russie
contre l'ukraine mais évidemment
l'ukraine n'ayant jamais accédé à l'otan
il est presque impossible pour les
occidentaux pour les alliés d'intervenir
militairement en ukraine sans déclencher
ce qui ressemblerait à une troisième
guerre mondiale la faute elle incombe à
la russie qui attaquent sans aucun
prétexte valable son pays voisins denis
car elle est ce que les présents
zelensky raisons de se sentir seul apes
ce premier jour de guerre bah écoutez on
savait que si elle avoir une guerre
comme sur tout azimut que les ukrainiens
seraient seuls offrant évidemment avec
tous les puits international
diplomatiques économiques politiques et
cetera mais il reste que les ukrainiens
sont seuls pour se battre il ya déjà eu
vous avez mentionné lors 530 540 morts
chez les militaires
des centaines de blessés par ailleurs
des centaines de blessés des civils des
civils qui ont péri alors évidemment
quand gouvernement russe nous dit on
vise pas les civils on oublie ça
je pense que c'est assez clair que tout
ce que dit le gouvernement russe est pas
tout à fait fondés mais il faut saluer
tout de même le courage exceptionnel de
deux ukrainiens et à commencer par le
président parce que vous savez si qui
elle est pour tomber
les dirigeants à commencer par zelensky
vont tous est arrêté par
dans les russes et puis on sait ce qui
va arriver par la suite c'est ceux des
journées très tragique
mais ce que qui elle va tomber
lorsque la résistance va se poursuivre
la première journée tout de même c'est
très inquiétante
oui parce qu'on a l'impression que toute
la force militaire de la russie s'est
abattue sur sur l'ukraine de tous bords
de tous côtés et que on a l'impression
que l'ukraine n'a pas pu riposter à la
même hauteur
en fait ce que les experts militaires
nous disait déjà dans la politique du
pire s'ils étaient pour avoir invasion
c'est que
l'armée russe allait viser
essentiellement les infrastructures
militaires à commencer par les aéroport
militaire d'ukrainiens pour anéantir la
flotte ukrainienne la flotte de
l'aviation c'est plus ou moins ce qui
est arrivé aujourd'hui puisque de toute
façon l'aviation russe et peut-être dix
fois plus puissantes que l'aviation
ukrainienne alors une fois vous
contribuer le ciel puis les aéroport
mais là la russie peut commencer à
transporter des troupes
par l'air et non pas seulement par par
l'infanterie sur le sol donc on est loin
des terres mais égale même puisque novak
vous êtes qu'on n'a pas donné les
garanties de sécurité à l ukraine il ya
le président français macron aujourd'hui
qui a passé un coup de fil à poutine le
poutine a pris l'appel de macron est
illusoire de penser qu'on puisse
encore espérer
une sortie de crise de guerre
diplomatique étant donné que
l'europe est loin d'avoir été bernés
jusqu'à maintenant pas poutine je ne
pense pas que la page jeu diplomatique
est ouverte et je ne pense pas qu'il
s'ouvrira bientôt parce que le kremlin
est sur une lancée l'armée l'armée russe
est en train de prendre le dessus puis
les capacités relative sont l'écart est
tellement grandes en les capacités que
c'est pas étonnant du tout
je milite toujours pour des solutions
diplomatiques mais je ne pense pas que
la diplomatie puisse faire quelque chose
au moment où on se parle c'est très
difficile de l'arrêter puis je pense que
il s'arrêtera quand le nécessaire sera
fait en fait dans le but sera atteint
est-ce que ça va être hué tant de
toute l'ukraine
je pense plutôt de mettre le régime
fidèle loyal en ukraine plutôt que de
s'en emparer donc s'en emparer
indirectement oui ce très certainement
mais pas
diplomatiquement pas au niveau 2 en fait
deux
d'engloutir en fait une crème de la
faire adhérer à la fédération de russie
macron président de l'europe qui par la
poutine est ce que ça a un effet
quelconque
autant j'ai cru comme ekaterina
puisqu'on ovale à l'option de diplomatie
là je pense que je suis assez perplexe
devant
des gestes d'ouverture à l'endroit de
vladimir poutine le président baden bien
de vie la véritable sanction qu'on peut
imposer aujourd'hui à la russie c'est
celle d'en faire un état paria de lancer
le message que cette quête de grandeur
mais pas prise au sérieux que la russie
sera coupée du reste du monde j'allais
dire du reste du monde mais en fait du
monde occidental parce que évidemment la
russie jusqu'à maintenant compte sur le
silence j'ai envie de dire presque
coupable de la chine qui est son
meilleur allié dans sa tentative de ne
pas être ce qu'elles seraient autrement
un pays complètement isolé sur la scène
internationale
mais on a l'impression par contre que
poutine s'était préparé à se voir
imposer des sanctions et qu'il est
presque indifférent à ces sanctions
avant même puisque nova il a parlé assez
à son élite économique aujourd'hui et
semblait dire entre que je ne posait pas
de problème là pour l'épauler russie et
que jamais oui mais en fait j'ai lu les
dernières données la fortune de vagues
et alekperov qui est un des amarres nat
pétrolier russe a diminué à 2 5
milliards si on croit aux
données qui sont plus ou moins
officielle d'un jour lui en reste
peut-être autant
il va pas mendier dans la rue demain ça
c'est sûr et certain mais quand même ça
fait mal à l'entourage proche à
l'entourage oligarchique
on s'est quand même
dans l'histoire de la russie il y avait
un combat de crem lab du kremlin avec
les oligarques un combat qui a été gagné
donc les eaux les garçons pas mal à
dompter leurs capacités de d'influencé
sur poutine à court terme me semble
minime pour vous de michael sur ces
sanctions est ce qu'elles sont à la
hauteur des de la menace
d'écouté avec les sanctions on sait que
ça va pas du tout ralentir poutine dans
son idée de détruire la souveraineté de
l'ukraine ce que le président byden
chercher à vendre aujourd'hui c'est que
si effectivement il ya une résistance
ukrainienne beaucoup plus
considérables que poutine et les russes
attendent
autrement dit si la guerre va pas durer
quatre à cinq jours avant que kiev tôt
mecs opéra mais là les sanctions à moyen
terme peut-être d'ici un mois d'ici deux
mois pourrait affaiblir la russie parce
qu'évidemment ça coûte énormément cher
de dominer une guerre comme ça puis
d'occuper un pays mais ça reste mince
comme possibilités de comme levier pour
essayer d'influencer la situation sur le
terrain tu as bien on va aller à une
pause tous les trois vous restez avec
nous au cours des prochaines minutes
jusqu'à 21h vous serez avec nous pour
réagir aux développements de la
situation en ukraine du retour on va
s'entretenir avec un expert qui
décortique la stratégie militaire russe
a tout de suite
vous l'avez vu sur ici redit tout était
planifié jusqu'à ce moment de vladimir
poutine qui après avoir rencontré son
conseil de sécurité vient de reconnaître
après huit ans de conflit ce que lui
considère l'indépendance l'autonomie de
deux territoire ukrainien où les forces
pro russes tiennent tête depuis huit ans
avec l'aide de moscou toute l'actualité
en direct et en continu sur ici et redit
quoi qu'il arrive
et si votre cv pouvaient être adaptées
améliorée
s'il vous offrait la chance d'être vu
un cv indeed travail 116 pour vous
voyagez au québec être dépaysé en
sécurité c'est possible à l'hôtel musée
premières nations de wendake et vivez
une relâche en famille digne des plus
grandes expériences de nuitées les repas
au restaurant de l'hôtel quatre
activités culturelles interactives dont
la visite du site traditionnel au
norwich et daqui l'axé privé à la
piscine et au team pour seulement 789 $
hôtel première nation point ca pour
vivre une culture légendaire
[Musique]
chez le beau vitres d'autos on sait
qu'un bris dans le tas brise ça peut
vite arriver et ça peut compromettre
votre visibilité et votre sécurité fait
remplacer votre pare-brise maintenant et
obtenez en cadeau une carte prépayée de
25 $ faites vite vous avez jusqu'au 6
mars koné rendez vous dès maintenant
nous avons avancé une impressionnante
offensive militaire contre l'ukraine le
président russe vladimir poutine a
déclaré que ses troupes avaient atteint
leurs objectifs les pays voisins de
l'ukraine se prépare à accueillir des
dizaines de milliers de réfugiés
ukrainien qui fuient leur pays les etats
unis imposent à la russie de sévères
sanctions économiques et technologiques
le président byden averti son homologue
russe que son pays serait très cher
cette attaque le canada impose de
nouvelles sanctions membres de l'élite
russe et à la gare de rapprocher de
vladimir poutine les états unis vont
envoyer 7000 militaires supplémentaires
en allemagne pour rassurer leurs alliés
de l'otan vous êtes sûr et certain
[Musique]
vivez le vieux québec comme nulle part
ailleurs vivez l'hôtel manoir victoria
par affaires ou simplement pour
décrocher du quotidienne laissez-nous
pensez à votre bien-être car ici c'est
vous d'abord
profiter de nos heures de détente et de
l'invitant piscine intérieure goûter au
bonheur en savourant l'excusé nordique
de son restaurant chez bull et bistrots
boréale
l'hôtel manoir victoria l'hôtel 4
étoiles au coeur du vieux-québec
fait une entrée remarquée dans la
nouvelle année grâce à la gamme de
véhicules emblématiques de quasi l'arc
plongez vous dans le luxe sans compromis
de notre gamme de virus ou de berlines
exceptionnelle car le moment ne pouvait
être mieux choisi pour commencer l'année
en beauté
profiter de taux de location à partir de
1,9 pour cent pendant 24 mois sur la
plupart des modèles 2022
effectué une visite virtuelle
personnalisée de nos véhicules à
cadillac point live les décrypteurs
samedi 11h30 ici hardy quoi qu'il arrive
le sous titrage de cette émission vous
est présenté par les cyclos recyclé
gratuitement vous en politique
fluorescents usagers ils étaient
recyclés au point ca pour trouver un
point de dépôt
[Musique]
quand nous nous sommes réveillés ce
matin le monde était différente la
russie a lancé une attaque brutale
et non provoquée contre l'ukraine la
russie a donc prouvé au monde entier la
véritable nature du régime de vladimir
poutine ils sont les seuls responsables
de cette crise qu'ils ont créée par la
désinformation la manipulation et la
mauvaise foi nous ne pouvons pas
permettre à poutine de redessiner les
cartes et de décrire l'histoire pour
servir ses propres objectifs
le premier c'est les ministres fédéraux
aujourd'hui à la longue de nouvelles
sanctions contre les dix meilleures
poutines contre la russie et tous les
observateurs qui appréhendaient une
invasion croyais que ça viendrait de
l'est ou des républiques autoproclamées
et
même s'il y avait des trous partout du
bélarus et tout le long de la frontière
une très très longue frontière je
pensais de 1000 km alors mes cellules de
tous les bords de tous les côtés
aujourd'hui alors qu'elle est donc que
cette stratégie militaire de poutine est
ce que l'otan est interpellé maintenant
notamment par la pologne mon invité
richard blanchette major général à la
retraite les forces armées canadiennes
consultant en sécurité qui connaît bien
le temps
bonsoir monsieur
blanchette l'agent général blanchette
bienvenue à 24,60 êtes vous surpris
j'ose dire admettre de l'efficacité de
l'agression russe aujourd'hui qui est
venu de toutes parts
effectivement les résultats que l'on
semble décrire à l'heure actuelle sont
sont assez impressionnants mais il ne
faut jamais perdre de vue que la
première victime en temps de guerre
c'est toujours la vérité il faut se
laisser de l'espace de l'espace temps
pour comprendre comment cette interface
entre
le pouvoir politique ou plus précisément
le président poutine et les autorités
militaires 7 cette star de la manoeuvre
s'est peut-être pas un terme très
positif pour décrire ce qui se passe sur
le terrain mais c'est quand même une
réalité il y à haut niveau stratégie un
désir assez assez claire de s'emparer de
l'ensemble de l'ukraine ce qui implique
des mouvements vraiment en profondeur
l'utilisation de missiles de longue
portée pour réussir à mettre une
pression et préparer vraiment le champ
de bataille pour les étapes subséquentes
sans oublier bien sûr tous la paix
l'aspect cyber où
l'aspect des communications
électroniques ou de la guerre
électronique qui doit avoir lieu en
parallèle avec celui
de l'aveu même du président a
quand même eu de nombreux morts du côté
des militaires le crâne confirme la
prise de contrôle de tchernobyl et sa
région par les russes de la prise de
différents aéroports dit militaire qui
servait donc aux opérations on a
l'impression après le jour un qui a une
domination russe pour le moment on se
pose la question la capacité militaire
de l'ukraine avec moins grand nombre de
soldats de de résister à cette agression
qu'est ce qu'on en sait
je pense que la pénétration qui a eu
lieu de ce tournoi est ce la hauteur de
ker kiev a vraiment eu un impact sérieux
sur le plan de campagne cette
pénétration là mais probablement
beaucoup de pression sur la défense
ukrainienne parce qu'il risque d'y avoir
un double mouvement de pinces c'est à
dire avec les forces qui qui sont au
bélarus et un seul qui vont arriver par
7,7 cette voie centrale si vous voulez
et un deuxième mouvement de pince avec
les possibilités de d'arrivée du côté de
ça et même les forces russes qui sont
stationnée en crimée alors ça ça cause
certainement des démos plus que des maux
de tête aux forces d'ukrainiens dans
sens où ils doivent surveiller leurs
deux flancs ouais on attend le président
céline ce qui dans une première
déclaration plutôt aujourd'hui disait la
russie poutine veut décapité le régime
donc en ciblant kiev est ce que ça veut
dire que des xive
si les russes devaient s'emparer de kiev
la capitale est-ce que ça amène
nécessairement une capitulation une fin
de
fin de régime pour céline ski avec un
sort inconnu
la notion de commandes devrait contrôler
et absolument
essentiel ici dans l'analyse et
effectivement si les autorités
militaires père de contact avec les
autorités civiles si elle se retrouve
avec un certain flou au niveau
stratégique ça va se répercuter
directement sur la campagne de défensive
que les ukrainiens sont en train de
mettre sur pied les canadiens
aider dans leur planification les forces
les forces du kenya nous n'avons plus de
300 documents qui ont été ou trois bus
de militaires qui ont qui ont aidé à
cette préparation là et nous avons
entraîné plus d'une trentaine d'un
millier d'ukrainiens alors il est il est
quand même possible qu'avec le courage
de ces deux s'efforcent qu'il y ait des
combos bord et qui vont être encore plus
difficile quand on va arriver dans les
agglomérations
il ya une très grosse différence entre
les déferlements auquel on peut
s'attendre sur avec avec des tanks qui
est dit
des transporteurs de troupes dans du
terrain ouvert mais quand on arrive dans
les agglomérations ce sont des combos
beaucoup plus difficile et il ya fort à
parier que les ukrainiens vont être
quand même prêt à
résister évidemment il ya 3400 troupes
qu'on envoie pourra citer le temps
poutine a peur de l'otan avait pas que
l'ukraine adhère à l'otan alors qu'ils
n'avaient pas de plan d'adhésion sam été
refusé l'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan
dans le passé déjà et donc mais putin
social que ça ne leur est assurée pas et
la pologne demande aujourd'hui
interpelle le temps qui va se réunir
demain pour dire écoutez l'article 4 la
consulter nous parce qu'on se sent
menacée consulter nouveau entre ce qu'on
peut faire vous connaissez bien le temps
pensez-vous que l'otan peut décider de
faire quelque chose pour protéger
l'ukraine parce qu'on a l'air de dire je
le dis les autres dit pas question
d'envoyer des troupes sur le terrain
alors qu'est ce que le temps que j'ai eu
la chance de servir à l'otan pendant
trois ans dont la période où
nous avions à décider de quelle façon le
plan d'adhésion à l'otan à la fois de la
géorgie et de l'ukraine était considéré
lors du sommet
je me souviens pertinemment delà de la
difficulté à considérer une telle chose
parce que le risque était tellement
agréable de de froisser les russes et
les russes étaient à cette réunion le
président poutine lui-même était à cette
réunion et nous sentions déjà hélas il
faut se replacer que c'est 2008 que la
situation était vraiment intolérable du
point de vue du point de vue russe et il
ne faut pas il ne faut pas oublier que
cette
que cette situation dans l'ensemble
s'est envenimée encore encore plus bien
sûr à partir de 2014 quand la crimée a
été riche en veille alors je pense que
l'otan est dans une situation
extrêmement pénible d'être témoin d'une
situation qui pratiquement irréversible
j'essaie d'imaginer de quelle façon
les mini force ukrainienne pourrait
résister à la force vraiment supérieur
des virus et ce n'est pas vraiment un
joli tableau et c'est pourquoi toutes
les personnes que vous interrogez ont
l'air plutôt lugubre y avait aujourd'hui
est ce que c'est ce qu'on peut imaginer
une situation de crise d'abord on aurait
pu dire avant la guerre on aurait pu
dire
l'ukraine ne renonce pour un certain
nombre d'années adhérer à l'otan pour un
pain donner le temps de la paix et
peut-être donné le temps à poutine de
quitter le pouvoir mais en même temps
est-ce que ça se fait ça s'imagine soit
que disons demain dans leurs réunions et
10 b finalement on va accepter l'ukraine
dans le temps pour amener une
intervention des pays de la table parce
que même maintenant craignent peut-être
que poutine aille au delà de l'ukraine
aille vers les pays baltes aille vers la
pologne
la moldavie
en termine avec le scénario que vous
décrivez si jamais il y avait un
débordement et ce risque est absolument
réels les risques de dérapages sont son
immense actuellement les possibilités
qu'il y avait une mauvaise
interprétation de ce que font les russes
ou de ce que fait l'otan c'est une c'est
une réalité tout à fait concrète here
ce risque doit être géré par l'otan
parce que là on parle carrément d'une
guerre qui qui pourrait glisser vers
l'utilisation de d'armes nucléaire
biologique chimique
parce que ça pourrait devenir vraiment
un théâtre encore plus explosif que ce
que nous avons actuellement on ne parle
pas beaucoup de ses possibilités là mais
c'est toujours dans le background et
enoh aux militaires canadiens
s'entraînent pour c'est pour ces
réalités là et il faut se rendre compte
que nos forces dans le camp les derniers
10 15 ou presque 20 ans maintenant on
beaucoup plus travaillée contre des
notions de d'insurrection que d'être
impliqué dans des sur un champ de
bataille à haute et artistique comme
celui qu'ils ont est en train de se
dessiner en r mon disent pas très
rassurante jean blanchette consultant en
sécurité mais major général à la
retraite avec une longue expérience donc
non seulement des forces armées mais en
europe et notamment à l'otan merci
monsieur blanchette on se reparle
c'est moi qui vous remercie pour
l'excellente couverture que je partage
avec mon équipe et je parle fort une
bonne pensée pour nos correspondantes
sur le terrain marie-eve bédard et amar
altéré sco qui prennent même pas une
petite minute pour aller se reposer et
couvrir tous les aspects de cette guerre
merci beaucoup
sûrement
selon le président et les disques et les
attaques ont fait 137 morts c'est lui
qui le confirme et un peu plus d'une
heure
maryse est belle
vous nous résumer ce déploiement
militaire
d'aujourd'hui c'est un déploiement qui a
commencé très tôt ce matin on a vu donc
des frappes aériennes des blindés aussi
se déplacer et au total ça faisait
plusieurs semaines que l'on qu'on le
voyait autour de l'ukraine donc près de
190 mille soldats russes qui étaient aux
frontières est ce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui
tout d'abord on a vu des blindés se
déplacer aux frontières à partir des
frontières du bélarus est rentré par le
nord en ukraine on a aussi vu des
blindés rentrée par la frontière avec la
crimée et l'ukraine on a vu plusieurs
images d'attac une des stratégies d re
c'était d'attaquer les bases militaires
des ukrainiens les aérodromes également
ce qu'on voit ici c'est une base
militaire amélie topol qui a été attaqué
on a vu aussi à kiev la tacc du quartier
général du renseignement ukrainien aussi
se faire attaquer ici ce qu'on voit mais
c'est tchernobyl on a eu plusieurs
craintes aujourd'hui parce que elle et
russes ont mis la main sur l'ancienne
centrale nucléaire de tchernobyl où on y
retrouve des déchets nucléaires depuis
l'incident 1986 et le président jeanine
ce qui a qualifié cette attaque d'attac
contre l'europe on s'inquiétait
justement raison donc de ces déchets
militaires qui se trouvaient est ce
qu'on voit ici mais c'est une attaque
d'un aéroport à mario paul donc plus à
l'est du pays au total les russes ont
déclaré avoir attaqué 74 installations
militaires et d'avoir attaqué aux
aérodromes et ce soir donc le président
jeanine ce qui a déclaré que près de
cent trente sept soldats ont été tués
évidence bien évidemment c'est un bilan
qui est provisoire actuellement 3 116
soldats qui ont été blessés et le
président heinz qui a fait un appel à la
mobilisation militaire général très bien
alors on se reparle un petit peu plus
tard au cours de l'émission marc
isabelle alors merci beaucoup alors au
retour les conséquences économiques de
la vision russe puisque on va évaluer le
poids des sanctions
occidental que valve tel avec quels
effets a tout de suite
[Musique]
et
l'esl est les sirènes ont retenti dans
plusieurs villes de l'ukraine
aujourd'hui pour donner la lettre de
cette agression russe qu'on appréhendait
bien sûr ce soir la situation est plus
calme et fait nuit mais l'armée russe se
rapprochent de la capitale ukrainienne
kiev à l'aube d'une deuxième journée de
combats la première journée de style it
et a fait 137 morts
chez les militaires selon le président
de links qui des milliers de déplacés on
va en parler d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
de ces réfugiés et ont fait le point on
a fait le point en début d'émission avec
nos correspondantes marie ève bédard et
camara lt lt resco sur le terrain de
chaque côté de la frontière on vous
présente un court extrait de leur
intervention
les évacuations organisée par le
gouvernement ont commencé autour de
14h15 heure par autobus par trait on a
dit maintenir tous les trajets des
princes sauf dans les endroits où
vraiment c'était impossible il fallait
faire trop d'efforts pour dérouter les
liens ferroviaires donc on a cherché à
faire partir les gens de cette région
avec l'imposition de cette loi martiale
ça facilite mais on a aussi reproché au
gouvernement de la russie de faire la
sourde oreille aux appels qui ont été
envoyés par le gouvernement ukrainien
pour établir un corridor sécuritaire
pour que ces évacuations là puisse se
faire dans le calme vous parliez de ces
gens qui se réfugient dans le métro ça
je vous dirais qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
peu le privilège des gens qui habitent
les grandes villes d'avoir ces endroits
sous terre pour pouvoir passer la nuit
ils sont massés dans toutes les stations
de métro ici à kiev mais à kharkhiv
aussi est là sans savoir ce que la nuit
leurs réserves il reste encore plusieurs
heures avant de voir si une opération
massive va être lancée sur la capitale
kiev mais c'est clairement ce qu'on
redoute le plus fort en ce moment on les
écoute
à noter qu'ils
obéissent
j'ai
beaucoup d'amis
ici
samedi pour homicide
c'est
les ukrainiens s'étaient préparés ils
ont gardé leur sang froid et les choses
se font dans l'ordre aujourd'hui mais
cette peur dans cette jeune fille parle
elle est bien présente on la sent
partout il ya cette angoisse et
l'incertitude de ce qui vient demain des
gens n'imaginaient pas l'ampleur de la
tâche qui est en train de se dérouler en
ce moment alors on craint que ça puisse
de plus en plus dégénéré ils ont
commencé à s'armer les ukrainiens le
gouvernement distribue maintenant
ouvertement à tous ceux qui le
souhaitent des armes pour pouvoir
défendre les villes les place un peu
partout au pays camara intéresse qu
bonsoir les autorités russes afin
maintenant qu'elles ont rempli avec
succès leur mission que tous les
objectifs ont fixé au 1er jour de
l'invasion c'est un succès
donc premier jour de combien de jours
c'est ça la question qui se pose ici
j'écoutais marie-eve puis c'est un peu
absurde d'être si près mais de se sentir
si loin parce que nous on est du côté
d'où toute cette artillerie est lancée
mais on n'en voit pas les conséquences
et les ententes comme ça c'est sûr et
elle sera elle aussi parce que ce qu'on
diffusait la télévision ici le russe
moyen qui se fit comme sur l'information
à la télévision d'état n'a pas les
témoignages qu'on vient d'entendre n'a
pas les
le bilan des victimes via sûrement des
soldats russes qui sont morts
aujourd'hui et s'est pas laissée par la
télévision la télévision d'état qui qui
va leur apporter ici ce qu'on rapporte
c'est toujours que c'est une mission
d'autodéfense si les seuls deux
ukrainiens se rendent ils seront bien
traités il ya une manipulation très
certainement de ce qui est encore décrit
comme une intervention qui était
nécessaire
de quitter une question de vie ou de
mort pour la pour la survie du peuple
russe et les médias sont très limités
dans ce qu'ils peuvent diffuser on a
tous reçu sur le téléphone ce matin des
avertissements qui s'appelle censure
militaire et qui prévient les
journalistes qu'ils doivent se limiter à
diffuser des informations qui ont été
corroborées ou fournis par le ministère
de la défense ça c'est sous peine mende
ou de france administrative qui dans le
cas des journalistes étrangers peuvent
être peuvent mener à une expulsion n'a
qu'un contrôle de l'information alors
qu'on est en train de parler
du plus grand conflit en europe depuis
la 2 mondial
j'enchaîne maintenant sur le volet
économique parce que les experts nous
disent qu imposer des sanctions c'est un
prix pour ceux qui les imposent alors on
est confronté ces sanctions va se
demande un peu plus tard si elles vont
assez loin pour dissuader poutine dont
attendant mon collègue gérald fillion
examine pour nous l'impact sur les
marchés notamment après ce premier jour
de guerre bon soir gérard au soir anne
marie beaucoup de volatilité je vous
dirais sur les marchés aujourd'hui
forte baisse en début de journée forte
hausse dans l'après midi mais ce qui
retient davantage notre attention bien
sûr c'est le pétrole
le baril de pétrole on mettra pas ses
tableaux là parce qu'on comprendra pas
très bien il ya d'autres tableaux le
pour montrer donc le pétrole le pétrole
aujourd'hui était à près de 106 dollars
le baril en cours de séance un sommet
depuis 2014 en hausse de 1 8% de 8% par
rapport à ce qu'on avait vu la veille et
à la fermeture 99 dollars en hausse de
2,2 pour ça alors le président by donne
aux etats-unis prévoient utiliser les
réserves stratégiques de pétrole s'il
manque de pétrole dans le marché
international
ça c'est une chose sur les marchés
boursiers attendez-vous à beaucoup de
volatilité au cours des prochains jours
si ce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui new york et
toronto ont terminé en progression alors
qu'en europe on était en baisse et à
moscou la bourse de moscou a chuté de 30
8% aujourd'hui avec des baisses pour
gazprom pour sberbank notamment alors
l'effet économique est déjà très
important sur les marchés russe mais
puisque la russie est un acteur de
premier plan sur l'énergie
40% du gaz naturel d'europe vient de
russie 25 % du pétrole d'europe vient de
russie et le tiers du gaz naturel qui
est acheminé par la russie vers l'europe
est principalement vers l'allemagne
passe par l'ukraine le tiers donc on
s'attend bien sûr à des soubresauts et
des incertitudes sur sur sur le pétrole
principalement sur l'énergie en tout cas
n'a pas fermé le robinet encore non mais
si on ferme le robinet l'impact est
désastreux pour l'allemagne et pour
l'europe il est désastreux pour les
russes donc il ya personne qui intérêt à
ce qu'il y ait un ralentissement de
l'exportation de pétrole et de gaz russe
tandis que poutine ce deal quand il
déclenche une guerre les sports
mais ce qui aura on connaît de très très
forte inflation qui en décourage
plusieurs vous avez abordé ce sujet là
il récemment dans une émission spéciale
mais est ce que cette guerre
particulièrement aura un impact sur
l'inflation probablement si les russes
se retrouvent dans une situation ils
peuvent moins exporter de pétrole s'il
ya des menaces de la part de vladimir
poutine pour ralentir l'exportation
énergétique le prix du baril de pétrole
qui est à 100 dollars aujourd'hui pour
être à 120 puis à 150 dollars dans ces
circonstances ça veut donc dire une
pression et passionné supplémentaire
avec un prix de l'essence qui pourrait
monter de l'art 80 dollars 85 le litre
il pourrait y avoir une inflation sur
les aliments plus grande également le la
russie c'est un important producteur de
grains alors ça ça pourrait affecter les
aliments l'inflation alimentaire avec
les prix de l'énergie du transport qui
augmente il pourrait y avoir des effets
également cela dit il ya un mot que je
veux prononcé ici ce soir c'est le mot
stagflation qui est employé par les
économistes pour dire que nous sommes
dans une situation où l'économie
mondiale pourrait ralentir donc stagner
tout en ayant de l'inflation de là le
mot stagflation et ça ce serait une
situation qui serait assez dommageable
sur le plan économique je vous fais
entendre là dessus le pdg de la caisse
de dépôt et placement du québec
et c'est certain qu'avec une hausse du
prix du gaz naturel en europe une hausse
du prix du pétrole
on peut exacerber ces deux facteurs
l'eau dans la même direction l'inflation
continue la croissance se modère
davantage l'inflation c'est pas grave
tant que de la croissance est ce qu'on a
vécu en 2021 eu des bons résultats mais
s'il ya de l'inflation et plus de
croissance sauf qu'une combinaison peut
plus délicate
oui un terminal gérald cid entrevue que
vous avez réalisé tout à l'heure son
économie mais quelle serait donc l'effet
économique pour le canada quand même on
impose aussi nous mêmes des sanctions ne
voudrait que l'importation de ce don qui
alors trois choses givi rapidement
premièrement on suspend l'émission des
permis d'exportation
mais ces 700 millions sur 500 milliards
d'exportation du canada donc l'impact
pour certaines entreprises certainement
eu un impact négatif mais l'impact sera
très modérée deuxièmement on produit
beaucoup de blé et de potasse nous
sommes des leaders au canada dans les
fertilisants et dans le blé et c'est la
même chose pour les russes et les
ukrainiens également les ukrainiens et
les russes et 25% du blé en termes de
production donc le canada n'est pas très
loin derrière le canada pourrait
bénéficier d'un ralentissement des
exportations de la russie de l'ukraine
et troisièmement le premier ministre
qu'est né en alberta dis moi j'ai du bon
pétrole à exporter davantage si jamais
l'europe devait manquer de pétrole russe
c'est peu probable que ça se passe comme
ça et que le pétrole canadien profite de
nouveaux marchés je serai davantage les
américains ou les saoudiens on peut
imaginer que les saoudiens pour
augmenter leur pétrole se dit ça
pourrait faire monter davantage le prix
du pétrole ce qui pourrait bénéficier à
l'économie canadienne je pars vraiment
en termes financiers ici là et à
l'économie albertaine qui incidemment
aujourd'hui gouvernement présenté un
surplus budgétaire pour son prochain
exercice parce que le prix du pétrole
étant beaucoup géraniums entretenir dans
un instant avec un député européen qui
dénonce l'hypocrisie européenne et qui
trouve qu'on n'a pas le courage d'aller
assez loin mais quelle sanction merci
jérôme là des maisons
oui
économique baisse
l'évasion de l'ukraine donc on apprenait
une multitude de sanctions contre moscou
où sont elles suffisantes j'ai fait le
point un peu plus tôt avec raphaël oxman
qui est député européen vice président
de la sous commission des droits de
l'homme du parlement européen
raphaël oxman bonsoir et bienvenue à
24,60
bonsoir réveil brutal pour tous les
européens j'imagine ce matin et vous
comme député également impliqué dans la
défense des droits de l'homme comment
avez vous vécu
ce jour 1 de la guerre de poutine contre
l'ukraine
c'est un jour extrêmement sombre
extrêmement sombre d'abord pour les
ukrainiens dont le seul crime est
d'avoir voulu vivre librement et
souverainement c'est un jour extrêmement
sombre si pour l'europe parce que c'est
l'ensemble de l'architecturé de sécurité
européenne qui est ébranlée aujourd'hui
et notre continent bascule dans la
guerre et tout cela à cause d'un homme
et d'un régime à cause de vladimir
poutine et à cause de son régime de
kleptocrates et de tyran et c'est un
jour extrêmement difficile c'est la fin
de l'irénisme et de l'innocence
européenne c'est le moment où on se rend
compte qu'un nouveau l'histoire est
tragique et qu'il va falloir se hisser
au niveau des périls qui nous font face
donc oui c'est un jour extrêmement
sombre et sérieux dans notre histoire
est ce que vous voyez des ressemblances
avec ce qui a été vécu à la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale alors que on
avait fait confiance à hitler et à
travers la diplomatie qu'on se retrouve
aujourd'hui parce que juste à l'est sud
est là que tu voulais
protéger mais là est ce que vous voyez
des ressemblances avec ses tvq
je vois surtout des ressemblances dans
notre naïveté dans notre incapacité à
imaginer et anticiper le pire vous savez
vladimir poutine il a pris le pouvoir en
1999 par une guerre en tchétchénie
ensuite il a envoyé en 2008 la géorgie
ensuite il a envahi l'ukraine en 2014
déjà et annexé la crimée occuper le
dombass ensuite il a rasé alep effet la
guerre en syrie et à chaque fois à
chaque fois on arrive on a cherché à lui
trouver des excuses à chaque fois on a
refusé de voir que la grande
confrontation qui voulait installer ce
n'était pas tant contre les georges
greiner où les syriens c'était contre
nous et donc on a fui devant nos
responsabilités on l'a laissé prospérer
on l'a laissé grandir on l'a laissé se
radicaliser et à aucun moment on a fait
les actions on a pris les mesures qui
ferait qu il nous prend au sérieux quand
on lui dit d'arrêter est donc là
finalement on a péché par naïveté mais
c'est toujours la même chose avec les
occidentaux allez soyons soyons honnêtes
c'est toujours la même chose on a du mal
à imaginer que quelqu'un ne pousse pas
notre propre rationalité et donc
jusqu'au bout les européens on pensa
qu'il bluffait sur le crem est en
réalité on s'est rendu compte de quoi et
bien que et ce type de tiran allés
jusqu'au bout de leur logique et qui va
faire nous qu'on assume le rapport de
force avec une ombre notre seule arme ce
sont des sanctions
sont-elles suffisantes à ce que ça va
assez loin selon vous
pour l'instant mon et ça fait seulement
24 heures il ya eu une réponse c'est
déjà bien une réponse unie de l'europe
c'est nécessaire c'est vital mais pour
l'instant les sanctions elles vont pas
assez loin giron n'arrive toujours pas à
s'accorder la sur le fait d'expulser la
russie du système bancaire international
et de swift on n'arrive toujours pas à
saisir les biens des oligarques qui sont
les piliers du régime russe et qui ont
des villas sur la côte d'azur des
chalets dans nos dans nos montagnes qui
ont des appartements pas loin d'ici dans
le 8e arrondissement de paris quartier
cossu le porte parole de vladimir
poutine monsieur peskov a des
appartements dans le huitième nul serait
c'est vraiment un test immense pour nous
dire si on n'est pas capables là de
frapper fort on ne sera jamais capable
de le faire et finalement l'ukraine
n'aura été qu'une étape et donc c'est un
vrai est ce un vrai test pour les
américains c'est un vrai test pour
l'ensemble des alliés occidentaux et
c'est surtout surtout un test pour nous
européens parce qu'à la fin c'est notre
sécurité qui est en jeu et vous savez à
travers l'ukraine c'est aussi l'europe
qui l'attaquent c'est aussi l'idée même
de démocratie
c'est c'est quelque chose qui est vital
pour nous on en sentira les conséquences
pendant des générations si on ne réagit
pas maman alors selon vous ne va pas
assez loin même je pense que vous parler
d'hypocrisie européenne un exemple
concret c'est la dépendance au gaz
d'autres rumeurs on n'a pas fermé le
robinet mais bien sûr déjà on a réussi à
convaincre l'allemagne de fermer de
suspendre leur stream 2 mais il ya un
problème fondamental vous avez vu la
réaction de medvedev lorsqu'on a décidé
de fermer dans trine 2 c'était un
chantage pur au gaz il faisait des
blagues sur le prix du gaz qui allait
être multiplié par deux eh bien il faut
s'émanciper du chantage russe sur le
gave tant que nous ne serons pas
capables de faire ça ne pourrons pas
nous dire réellement souverain et donc
il faut faire une union européenne de
l'énergie de manière extrêmement
sérieuse il faut il faut vraiment se
poser la question c'est dire est ce
qu'on veut vivre toute notre vie et bien
comme sous le chantage d'un tyran
lunatique où est ce qu'on va être
capable d'être autonome et s'ouvre et ça
c'est une réquisition de tous les
organes peuvent se poser parce qu'en
réalité est évidemment si on prend des
sanctions qui seront efficaces et qui
auront un impact à moscou eh bien ça
aura une forme de prix à payer pour les
épauler citoyens européens est-ce que
nous sommes prêts à payer le prix de la
liberté est ce que nous sommes prêts à
payer le prix de la souveraineté est ce
que nous sommes prêts oui à avoir deux
trois mois où le temps qu'on s'arrange
eh bien on paiera le prix du gaz plus
cher parce qu'on sera l'objet du
chantage de vladimir poutine mais si on
ne fait pas ce prix là maintenant quel
prix payera tontouta vivent sous la
menace permanente de quelqu'un comme
poutine ou de son régime eh bien ce
n'est pas une vie libre ce n'est pas une
vie digne ce n'est pas une vie
souveraine est donc là c'est vraiment un
moment de test du
jeu sans que que tout le monde à l'idée
qu'il se passe quelque chose d'important
et j'aimerais vraiment qu'on s'arrête et
qu'on comprenne ce qui se joue c'est à
dire que si on autorise ça vous ai fait
la comparaison avec les années 30 mais
si on autorise cette agression à cette
invasion sans aucune forme de
justification possible eh bien on se
prépare des années et des décennies
extrêmement violente extrêmement dur
partout en europe il et c'est vraiment
un moment où j'espère que nos dirigeants
j'espère que nos dirigeants quels que
soient leur couleur politique quelle que
soit leur nationalité celui seront au
niveau du fille qui nous est lancé par
la brutz kiabi qui abrite et qui habite
le kram a déjà des vies humaines
c'est un plus lourd à payer déjà
plusieurs sont tombés aujourd'hui en
ukraine
sous les attaques de poutine alors c'est
extrêmement trimestre c'est quand on est
bien bien sûr et juste avant de finir
j'aimerais vraiment dire à tous vos
téléspectateurs kiné qui ne connaissent
pas nécessairement lucre mg acquiesce
c'est comme c'est comme paris est une
ville européenne
c'est une grande ville européenne avec
des gens qui pensent à leurs études qui
pensent à leurs enfants qu'ils pensent à
leur travail mais qui ne pensait
absolument pas à la guerre moi je
connais bien cette ville je connais bien
le peuple ukrainien et la guerre lors
est tombé dessus mais comme une
malédiction divine et easy vivait comme
nous ils étaient comme nous et tout d'un
coup ils doivent faire face à l'invasion
russe et c'est vraiment un un désastre
est un crève coeur pour ceux qui
connaissent les ukrainiens pour ceux qui
ont vu à quel point est bien la nation
ukrainienne s'est soulevée par deux fois
en dix ans pour affirmer sa liberté pour
réclamer juste un droit qui est celui de
vivre comme nous en démocratie et c'est
ce crime là que la nation ukrainienne
est en train de payer donc défendre leur
liberté c'est aussi défendre notre
liberté c'est défendre la démocratie
face à un tyran qui ne s'arrêtera que si
on l'arrête rafale doc seaman merci
beaucoup de votre participation 24 60 et
je dirais même de votre plaidoyer merci
beaucoup merci
après la pause comment freiner poutine
l'invasion russe marque tels la fin de
l'ordre mondial mais l'invitation avec
nous au retour
[Musique]
sur matthew modine sein des grosses
temps overbooké raquette
bouillir ou indirecte facebook cowboys
et les noviciats ko puisque ice in the
rain protiviti ville journaux suite
marché national jordanien chips au
service
de la cia
le président alain ski qui lance un
appel à la mobilisation qui déplorait au
fond qu'un rideau de fer saab était sur
l'ukraine à nouveau seul était
envahi par la russie alors je poursuis
avec les invités de mener car elle
frédéric mayrand et madame puisque nos
vins katerina puisqu'on voit alors vous
avez entendu bons voeux bon soir vous
trois alors vous avez entendu le
plaidoyer du député européen et raphaël
glucksmann sans doute qui dénonçait un
peu l'hypocrisie européenne en
particulier me le fait aussi que ces
sanctions là ne font pas assez mal
devenu car elle qu'on a pas le courage
d'aller assez loin puisque cela ne fait
pas maintenant on va payer le prix
longtemps dit il mais pendant les
décennies question un test pour l'europe
mais pour le monde de michael
oui c'est un test c'est un test mais il
y reste que la question sécuritaire on
sait que l'otan va pas aller se battre
pour l'ukraine et l'ukraine même si les
sanctions étaient beaucoup plus sévère
aujourd'hui si on avait annoncé comme
que la russie se retirait du système
swift lors de transactions bancaires la
guerre se poursuivraient parce que
poutine c'est ce qui s'en vient au
niveau des écoles ou des sanctions
possibles et puis là le problème
évidemment le grand danger c'est que
l'ukraine tombe tombe
sous le rideau de fer comme le président
indique qu'il vient de mentionner le
rideau de fer ça veut dire quoi mais ça
veut dire aussi la fin de la démocratie
c'est ce que raphaël glucksmann a bien
insisté c'est la fin de la démocratie
ça va être un régime de répression en
ukraine les partis politiques vont une
belle ni les médias vont et indépendants
vont aussi être bannie ça va être
finalement le genre de politique qu'on a
réussi ou qu'on a observés dans le
donbass là depuis huit ans est-ce que
c'est déjà fait selon vous fait déjà
peine perdue
non je dis pas que c'est peine perdue
mais je dis si effectivement l'ukraine
et pour tomber vous aviez le militaire
qui disait que c'est difficile de
concevoir que le petit renne pourra
résister militairement
à la russie mais ceci dit vendée parfois
des guerres qui doivent être rapides de
peur s'enliser et puis le lien potentiel
peut-être d'insurrection de la part des
ukrainiens qui s'est maintenant frédéric
mayrand et là je vais vous citer une
déclaration de deux secrétaires d'état
manqué monsieur benken convient de
remettre qu'il a déclaré je constate
qu'à quelques colonnes c'est une
reporter de cnn il est convaincu que
le président russe va renverser le
gouvernement
l'ukrainien alors ce que ça voudrait
dire c'est qu'il ya un gouvernement pro
russe en ukraine qui évidemment pas dans
le temps mais ce que ça devient pas
aussi une menace à savoir que la russie
se rapproche des pays limitrophes et des
pays de l'otan et qu'il ya deux choses
il ya deux choses d'abord vladimir
poutine a effectivement dit que ce qui
le cherchait c'était la démilitarisation
de l'ukraine il est en train d'y
parvenir est ce qu'il a appelé de
manière tout à fait paradoxale à des
nazis piccone de l'ukraine c'est à dire
un changement de régime un régime qui
ressemblerait probablement à celui qui
existe désormais en biélorussie c'est à
dire à la solde ou fortement allié avec
la russie est-ce que ça pose une menace
pour le temps il faut voir quand même
qu'un des résultats qui n'étaient
certainement pas souhaité par la
demi-heure poutine c'est d'avoir
renforcé la solidarité au sein de l'otan
l'intérêt l'engagement des états unis
mais aussi du canada sur le front
occidental oriental pardon est beaucoup
plus fort qu'avant il va probablement
s'accentuer donc tout indique que les
pays de l'otan sont probablement
protéger mais il ya d'autres pays dans
la région pensant à la géorgie par
exemple qui se retrouve dans une
situation encore plus délicate peut-être
que l'ukraine aujourd'hui est ce que la
commune la communauté européenne va est
impuissante face à ce qui est inscrit qu
est ce qu elle est impuissante
oui dans la mesure
où elle n'a pas montré qu'elles étaient
en mesure de dissuader cette occupation
de l'ukraine mais en même temps il reste
à une attraction de l'europe en ukraine
qui peut constituer pas l'année
prochaine mais sur le long terme une
perspective d'avenir autre que pour ces
pays bas et puis raphaël glucksmann l'a
mentionné il ya encore beaucoup de
sanctions qui peuvent faire mal et
j'insiste là dessus des sanctions qui
font mal ce sont aussi des sanctions qui
font mal au pays qui les adoptent c'est
important si on veut montrer sa
solidarité il faut être prêt à accepter
une augmentation du prix du gaz et une
augmentation du prix du pétrole et la
disparition des touristes riche dans les
alpes où allons nous en même temps c'est
sûr faisait le point d'attaché avec
gérald madame de pisco nova vous avez
des amis en ukraine êtes en contact
régulier aussi comme dany carrel et donc
avec l'ukraine je vais vous citer une
rage ici je retrouve cette citation là
aujourd'hui d'un observateur l'histoire
l'ukraine et la russie sont liés par
l'histoire et par le st
alors comment voyez vous la suite vous
l'avenir de l'ukraine en fait j'aimerais
revenir la dénazification et l'usr mais
un mot qui est très judicieusement
choisis parce que le crâne et la russie
ont effectivement une histoire commune
une très forte de la lutte contre le
fascisme contre le nazisme donc c'est un
terrain qui est judicieux parce que ça
mobilise à la fois la population russe
dans cette attaque absolument
désastreuse il rappelle aussi qu on ait
des débuts quand fait des racines
communes
des deux peuples alors la faute à un
moment donné a sorti un article qui a
fait beaucoup de bruit il s'agit de nous
nous sommes un seul peuple
ce qu'il fait aujourd'hui ça contredit
complètement à 7 cette espèce de
batterie de valeurs communes dont il a
parlé assez en long et en large
on ne combat pas un peuple
frère de cette manière si donc je ne
pense pas que
l'invasion l'attaquent contre l'ukraine
se base sur une volonté de rétablir la
parenté c'est possible oui c'est un très
bon c'est un très mauvais moyen on va
dire je pense que ça a une explication
purement géopolitiques géostratégiques
que je dirais aussi et
il faut dire il y a quand même en
ukraine contemporaine en ukraine moderne
il y a des forces pro-russes authentique
y en a peut-être beaucoup mais il en
reste encore donc sur lequel il pourrait
compter et éventuellement en changeant
le régime mais il va toujours y avoir
une riposte et le traumatisme les
blessures que le peuple ukrainien vit
aujourd'hui ne s'oublieront tout
simplement pas en 2004 elle parce que le
peuple ukrainien un goûter est ce que ça
peut être
une certaine forme de démocratie cette
forme de liberté comme disait graf elle
oxman l'escrinet c'est comme si kiev
c'est paris sa des gens qui veulent
étudier qui on a en face des gens qui
lui ressemble beaucoup au fond puis qui
veulent pas revenir en arrière
tout à fait mais aussi le sentiment
national ukrainien s'est très fortement
développée depuis l'indépendance et
depuis maidan 2014 donc l'ukraine est
devenu plus ukrainienne qu'elle était au
sens d'identification à la nation et à
l'état ukrainien mais si je peux ajouter
un point sur ce que poutine semble
vouloir faire je dirais que là bien
mentionné la démilitarisation de
l'ukraine donc ce serait quoi là la
destruction de la force militaire et
puis bon le renversement du gouvernement
une espèce de gouvernement de vichy
d'autres collaborations lorsque tout de
même même si au début évidemment il ya
des électeurs relativement trop russe le
nom dans les régions est mais c'est une
chose d'être trop heureuse d'être aligné
sur la culture russe sur l'histoire
russe sur la mémoire c'en est une autre
d'accepter que la russie
en veillée ce avec son arme et toute
l'ukraine lasser on est passé à un autre
niveau mais là ce qui est pas tout à
fait clair encore si le plan est
vraiment de faire basculer toute
l'ukraine ou en fait opérer une
partition de l'écrin de la partition
elle avait déjà commencé avec le crime
et le dông bât son cycle dundas le
savent être ça va augmenter de 3 fois
la reconnaissance des républiques
autoproclamées ce fait se trouve en
basse mais là actuellement les
mouvements des troupes indique justement
que l'objectif semble être de contrôler
tout le territoire à l'est de kiev à
l'aise de rameuses rivière de nippes
euro ce qui pourrait laisser une espèce
d'ukraine coupée en deux une crainte
semi indépendante et demain profondément
affaibli emploi y revenir plus tard dans
le prochain segment de la carène pour
définir à ekaterina bychkova on poursuit
cette émission parce que face à la
menace russe l'europe est sur le
qui-vive donc est ce que les pays
frontaliers et l'ukraine sont menacés
j'ai joué plus tôt à varsovie en pologne
benjamin haddad directeur du centre sur
l'europe ou atlantique anti-olympique
banques américaines
l'amérique est spécialisé dans les
relations internationales
bonsoir benjamin haddad depuis varsovie
en pologne bonsoir alors justement vous
êtes en pologne à 750 kilomètres de kiev
à peu près comment avez vous vécu les
derniers événements cette cette invasion
de l'ukraine par poutine
c'est vraiment un moment très dur un
moment tragique pour l'europe je crois
que j'espère que ce sera un réveil on
dit souvent c'est un peu un cliché mais
je pense que c'est un réveil pour
l'europe de voir aujourd'hui une guerre
d'agression contre une population qu'ils
voulaient juste vivre librement et
dignement qui voulait se rapprocher de
l'union européenne de l'occident on a
voulu faire croire que ce genre de
choses ne pouvaient plus arriver sur
notre continent on avait eu des
avertissements avec la géorgie en 2008
l'ukraine déjà en 2014 mais là
effectivement on est passé dans une
toute autre dimension avec vraiment une
guerre telle qu'on n'en a pas vu en
europe depuis 70 ans et qu'on va en
tirer les conséquences le long terme
aujourd'hui en europe ouaip houten a
berné lara gut scène un prédateur
oui poutine a berné l'europe on a vu
beaucoup d'efforts diplomatiques c'est
un semaine c'était important d'essayer
de trouver une issue diplomatique
emmanuel macron la chaux joe biden ont
tous parlé avec vladimir poutine pour
essayer de relancer les accords de minsk
pour laisser relancer les négociations
sur les contrôles d'armement c'est la
limite poutine qui choisit de fermer la
porte à la diplomatie et de choisir
aujourd'hui la violence avec cette
invasion massive qui va visiblement bien
au delà simplement du dombass les
services de renseignement américains qui
jusqu'ici ne se sont pas trompés
soupçonne que vladimir poutine vise à
renverser le régime à kiev on a entendu
lundi soir un discours extrêmement
agressif et paranoïaque de la part du
président russe ni en même l'existence
de la nation ukrainienne donc on est ici
dans une vision très révisionnistes de
non seulement la relation entre la
russie l'ukraine mais mais l'ordre
international
en tant que tel craignez-vous que
poutine veut y aller au delà de
l'ukraine même jusqu'en pologne même
attaqué des pays de l'otan déjà la
pologne demande qu'on évoque l'article
les articles 4 et 5 de l'otan parce
qu'elles se sentent ces pays se sentent
visés dans la mire de poutine
je comprends que ces pays se sentent
visés ils ont recouvré leur souveraineté
il ya trente ans après avoir été sous
pression soviétique pendant des
décennies au sein du pacte de varsovie
ce sont des pays qui sont entrés dans
l'union européenne et l'otan justement
pour pouvoir retrouver leur liberté ils
entendent les discours révisionnistes de
vladimir poutine depuis des années ils
le voient les l'agressivité de la russie
à leurs frontières ils mettent en garde
leurs alliés de l'union européenne et
des états unis depuis des années on
aurait peut-être dû les écouter donc
c'est important de
marquer notre solidarité de marquer
notre réassurance on a vu joe biden et
les dirigeants européens dire que la
présence de l'otan serait renforcée en
europe centrale et orientale que ce soit
en pologne les états baltes en roumanie
c'est extrêmement important pour
dissuader vladimir poutine d'aller plus
loin aujourd'hui dans son escalade et
cette fuite en avant et qu'est ce qui
peut freiner vladimir poutine
alors écoutez je crois que dans les
prochains jours déjà on va voir les
états unis et l'union européenne prendre
des sanctions massives contre le régime
russe contre vladimir poutine et les
oligarques autour de lui on sait depuis
des années que ce régime kleptocratique
et corrompu bénéficie aussi de la vague
le mans de l'occident on voit des villas
en à vous de france au royaume uni des
avoirs qui sont cachés donc c'est
important je pense de les cibler de nous
rendre nous mêmes d'ailleurs plus
indépendantes plus souverain vis-à-vis
de la russie mais aussi de soutenir
l'ukraine soutenir l'ukraine sur le plan
économique de soutenir l'ukraine sur un
plan militaire de donner à l'ukraine les
moyens de se défendre quand cette
agression mais jamais à d'annoncer
beaucoup entretenu avec vous alors que
vous étiez aux états unis 30
aujourd'hui encore a fait l'éloge de
vladimir poutine en disant que c'était
d'abord en début de semaine indique
steve génial ce qu'avait fait poutine en
disant que le métal s'offre un pays avec
des sanctions a de dollars
oui c'est pas étonnant on sait que trump
a toujours voué une certaine admiration
pour vladimir poutine on voit la même
chose en europe à l'extrême gauche à
l'extrême droite les dirigeants
populistes en france jean luc mélenchon
eric zemmour marine le pen qui depuis
des années nous explique que la russie
est un allié que l'otan est l'agresseur
que finalement avoir un dirigeant fort
comme vladimir poutine c'est ce qu'il
faut à l'europe on voit aujourd'hui le
résultat je pense que les gens peuvent
assez bien j'ai de savoir s'ils le
veulent un dirigeant comme la dîmière
poutine intervenant quelques secondes
seulement le peuple ukrainien la neige
aujourd'hui dans des images est apeuré
bouleversé a pas vraiment de se
retrouver dans un régime russo pro-russe
vous les comprenez
je les comprends naturellement mais je
vois aussi beaucoup de courage beaucoup
de résilience et de force chez le peuple
ukrainien qui étend bien il faut le
rappeler depuis 2014 une guerre qui a
fait 14 mille morts qu'on a un peu
oublié une guerre qui a commencé parce
que les ukrainiens et rêver d'un
meilleur avenir proche de l'union
européenne brandissaient des drapeaux
européens sur la place maïdan dans les
rues de kiev ils vont se défendre ils
vont se battre il faut les y aider moi
je vois beaucoup de beaucoup de courage
et de détermination aujourd'hui chez ce
peuple ukrainien merci beaucoup benjamin
lancar métaux merci merci
pour retour l'europe se prépare déjà un
exode de réfugiés quelle sera l'ampleur
des conséquences humanitaires a tout de
suite
à tout le monde en parle hillary clinton
et louise penny martin st louis philippe
son génial yassim les comédiens de c'est
comme ça que je t'aime en direct
dimanche 20h ici radio canada prix
pour cerner les vrais enjeux
pour comprendre les impacts réels
pour ouvrir de nouvelles perspectives
pour y voir clair consultez-le appris
infos de radio canada familiprix coupe
ses prix pour la famille dimanche cette
semaine obtenez les probabilités d'en
sélectionner à 16 dollars 97 ou les
produits listerine à 5 dollars 97 la
family world seulement chez familiprix
partout à travers le monde les meilleurs
designers cri pour great escape les plus
belles montures tendance et cite ici au
québec que vos lunettes sont produites
en laboratoire en ce moment les montures
de notre collection privée tendances du
monde vous sont offertes en cadeau elles
sont gratuites
pour tous les dormeurs les glaçons les
bouillottes les étoiles les cuillères ou
un mélange de tout ça on a ce qu'il vous
faut le méli mélo est de retour pour une
durée limitée seulement chez dormez-vous
dormi pia portez vous bien au rendez
vous familiprix coupe ses prix pour la
famille livange cette semaine obtenez le
papier hygiénique les essuie-tout
essentiel à 4 dollars 97 ou des produits
de coloration l'oréal paris 9 dollars 97
miliband seulement chez familiprix
nous avons avancé l'impressionnante
offensive militaire contre l'ukraine le
président russe vladimir poutine a
déclaré que ses troupes avaient atteint
leurs objectifs les pays voisins de
l'ukraine se prépare à accueillir des
dizaines de milliers de réfugiés
d'ukrainiens qui fuient leur pays les
etats unis imposent à la russie de
sévères sanctions économiques et
technologiques le président byden averti
son homologue russe que son pays ferait
très cher cet acte le canada impose de
nouvelles sanctions membres de l'élite
russe et à la gare de rapprocher de
vladimir poutine les états unis vont
envoyer 7000 militaires supplémentaires
en allemagne pour rassurer leurs alliés
de l'otan vous êtes sûrs et cirdi
[Musique]
il nous a fallu beaucoup d'efforts pour
arriver jusqu'ici et dès le départ on
était sur la bonne piste
on a toujours donné une autre sans 10%
pour surmonter les défis on a gravi les
montagnes les plus exigeantes sans
jamais se laisser ralentir on s'est
donné pour mission de repousser nos
limites peu importe le type de terrain
nos premiers pas nous ont conduits
jusqu'ici et c'est cette soif d'aventuré
qui continue de nous inspirer
voici le nouveau ni sens
[Musique]
par nourrir pendant qu'on peut avoir un
horaire trop chargé
apparemment dans la charge et toute la
saveur sans travail les crises qui
minent à 90 calories par portion elles
sont étonnamment savoureuse voici enfin
de rubans orienter le ruban adhésif
révolutionnaire central suffisamment
puissant pour supporter un poids de 17
livres et demie sur la plupart des
surfaces vous emery a hérité en ruban
adhésif révolutionnaire qu'il supporte
efficacement tout objet sans crochet et
sans aucune ville visitez notre site
pour obtenir le ruban lnt pour un prix
de 19 dollars 99 vous recevrez 21 pieds
de rubans aériens des pour 19 dollars 99
ne tardez pas voici ce qu'il faut faire
[Musique]
le bilan du jour 1 de cette guerre est
déjà assez dramatique le président de
links qui parlait 237 morts mais chez
les soldats mais comme vous le voyez sur
ces images des milliers en ukraine
veulent fuir le pays trouvé refuge
quelque part et l' agence des nations
unies pour les réfugiés le hcr estime
qu'ils sont déjà au moins cent mille
déplacés et peut-être même plus marc
isabelle certains pays s'organisent
d'ailleurs pour accueillir les
ukrainiens ouais c'est qu'entre autres
de la pologne je vous montre ses images
captées aujourd'hui en fin de soirée
donc à la frontière entre la pologne et
l'ukraine
on estime environ à 15000 ukrainien qui
se sont rendus à la fraude frontières
pologne polonaise et la pologne a mis en
place environ 9 centres pour les
accueillir pour leur fournir à la fois
des médicaments la nourriture et je vous
montre aussi ses images captées quarts
vivent deuxième ville en importance en
ukraine on voit ces personnes on a vu
beaucoup de l'image de gens dans les
métros qui s'apprêtent aujourd'hui
maintenant à passer la nuit ils sont
plusieurs parce que on a vu des
bombardements entre autres de résidence
comme vous le voyez sur ces images et il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui ont tenté
de fuir l'ukraine il y avait de grands
bouchons de circulation toute la journée
dans les grandes villes entre autres à
kiev défilent aussi très importante au
guichet automatique pour retirer de
l'argent dans les épiceries également et
on a vu de grandes manifestations dans
les villes européennes pour demander
pour s'opposer à l'invasion des russes
en ukraine les weppes le hcr qui
demandent aux pays limitrophes de
laisser les frontières ouvertes pour le
moment merci beaucoup dans les mails
bonne soirée
c'est incroyable en 2022 qui aurait pu
penser qu'on se retrouverait aujourd'hui
dans une guerre c'est vraiment la tête
puis j'espère qu'on voit tous est uni
dans nombre pour se battre contre le
président poutine on va effectivement
offrir du support matériel et on va
offrir ouvrir la porte au sein du régime
qui peut accueillir les réfugiés et
comment mon invité françois odette est
professeur à l'école des sciences de
gestion de l'uqam et directeur de
l'observatoire canadien sur les crises
et l'aide humanitaire bonsoir france ô
des bons soirs alors c'est un phénomène
de migration qui va être important selon
vous va écouter dans les scénarios que
mes collègues ont évoqué un petit peu
plus tôt on a aussi des conséquences
éventuelles sur la population civile et
c'est ça que c'est sur l'analyse de
l'impact humanitaire on arrose au
scénario je devrai optimiste même si
c'est évidemment une tragédie
la guerre se termine relativement
rapidement il ya l'installation d'un
régime donc évidemment sous contrôle de
moscou et il n'y a pas de combat
d'insurrection une contre insurrection
comme on a pu observer par exemple en
syrie ce qui ferait en sorte qu'il y
aurait moins de déplacements de
population et si on va vers un scénario
comme celui là pour l'instant les
hypothèses quantitatif si vous me
permettez de déshumaniser un peu de
l'analyse on est autour d'environ 200
mille deux cent mille réfugiés c'est
quand même déjà beaucoup mais si on va
aux scénarios beaucoup plus pessimistes
qui tout aussi probable ou comme on
l'expliqué tout à l'heure le conflit
dégénère où il ya une
contre-insurrection une insurrection
c'est à dire des combats de rue encore
une fois dans un contexte un peu comme
comme on a vu peut-être en syrie il ya
là il pourrait y avoir 10 15% de la
population de l'ukraine qui pourrait
être portée à quitter le pays et on
parle à ce moment là avec une population
de plus de 40 quelques millions 44
millions donc d'un scénario de 4 à 8
millions personnes qui voudraient
quitter le pays alors vous voyez un peu
là la marge d'erreur est importante
à l'heure actuelle c'est difficile de
faire des analyses précises mais ça
démontre aussi l'envergure du problème
et comme le l'ont dit certains
politiciens aujourd'hui en europe et
même ici chez nous il faut que les
frontières soient ouvertes pour la
protection des civils ils permettent
évidemment la transit le passage des
frontières pour faciliter la protection
des civils on peut imaginer le drame ce
que ça représente pour des citoyens qui
se retrouve du jour au lendemain dans
une guerre de prendre la décision de
partir parce qu'on en a qui veulent
rester mais qui veulent partir vous
connaissez le ce déchirement là qu'est
ce que ça représente pour ces gens là de
tout abandonner et partir
bah écoutez si c'est évidemment ce
n'était pas dans les plans de deux
personnes en ukraine cette année je
crois que l'humanité avait passé après
ces deux années de pandémie travers
beaucoup de choses depuis la dernière
chose que que la population pense
évidemment c'était d'avoir à quitter sa
maison donc à tout et quitter son emploi
quitter son enracinement mais pas
seulement ça c'est aussi vivre dans
l'inconnu c'est pas avoir de projet
d'avenir donc toute la halle le syndrome
le syndrome psychologique associés à des
départs du drs mains de la violence et a
pas savoir si on voit un jour retourner
dans cette villa c'est évidemment une
grande grande tragédie humaine c'est la
grande tragédie des réfugiés sur la
planète il faut évidemment espérer que
le meilleur scénario survient malgré un
contexte terrible qui est le moins de
personnes possibles qui qu'ils soient
déplacés il faut encore une fois au
risque de me répéter ouvrir les
frontières absolument et et heureusement
le contexte ukrainien fait en sorte
qu'un nombre important de pays
limitrophes qui ont connu notamment les
grandes guerres et qui vont ouvrir leurs
frontières de ce qu'on entend évidemment
à travers le lit et la diplomatie
humanitaire aujourd'hui en raison de la
statue de ces réfugiés des ukrainiens
qui viennent d'un pays qui était qu'elle
est bien
relativement bien des gens qui sont
engagés dans leur société qu'ils ont du
travail qui étudie et c est ce que ça
fait une clientèle de réfugiés par l'onu
- le mont clientèle le plus facile à
accueillir que deux autres dans d'autres
circonstances bah écoutez dans la
perspective des réfugiés selon justement
les critères du haut commissariat pour
les réfugiés
c'est en fonction de la vulnérabilité
alors en principe on vous savez on en a
déjà discuté on devrait pas espérer
d'avoir des réfugiés sur cette base là
l'on parle plus d'immigration donc c'est
une l'immigration est évidemment à ce
moment là davantage organisées en
fonction des priorités sociales
domestique est la dimension donc des
réfugiés normalement il y en a
aujourd'hui plus de 20 millions sur la
planète alors il faut espérer qu'il y
aura pas un nombre important
d'ukrainiens qui s'ajouteront à ça mais
oui cela il ya été dit c'est certain que
la communauté ukrainienne d'ici
particulièrement vos favoriser
cette relation là avec avec des liens
familiaux on l'avait observé un peu
aussi lors des vagues de l'ouverture de
nos frontières avec les réfugiés syriens
notamment on avait vu ses sept cette
relation là mesdames en a comme la
communauté de syrienne était moins
importante allez on se pensait la
communauté ukrainienne c'est certain que
ça va faciliter ce rapprochement
l'ouverture de nos frontières
intervenant à ce qu'on parle de plus
d'un million et demi du crédit au canada
surtout dans l'ouest en ontario tout ça
reste que le gouvernement trudeau
annoncé qu'il faciliterait la réunion
des familles donc ces deux temps soit
dans ce drame ça ça reste une bonne
nouvelle
complètement et puis évidemment c'est la
pression domestique la politique
domestique qui vont jouer à ce niveau-là
cela et en étant donné aussi
l'importance médiatique qu'on va porter
ce conflit-là par rapport à d'autres
actuellement sur la planète il y aura
certainement aussi des pressions
importantes pour que les frontières
soient ouvertes à la communauté
ukrainienne merci françois audet ça me
fait plaisir
au retour les ambitions de vladimir
poutine s'arrêteront elle acquiert
annoncé l'ambassadeur canadien nick
flynn est avec nous a tout de suite et
nous
[Musique]
moi je suis enragé je suis enragé parce
que nous nous avons fait beaucoup
d'efforts mais la russie c'est un
gouvernement terroriste les mêmes des
sanctions économiques etc et pas de pas
qu'ils vont vraiment parler ce langage
de poutine qui lui ne parle pas en terme
économique c'est un dictateur il
n'écoute que la langue de la force on
demande à la communauté internationale
des disparus distraction
quand la russie et que
en fait il ya plus de live de militaires
et économiques qui volent à l'ukraine
ces jeunes de la diaspora ukrainienne à
montréal veulent une ukraine libre
souveraine
démocratique qu en est il de l'avenir je
vais poursuivre avec mes invités là
dessus madame puisque innovant qu'est ce
qu'on aurait pu faire de mieux ou plus
pour ne pas en arriver là selon
l'histoire ne connaît pas de
conditionnel ce qui est fait c'est fait
on peut parler de repos les réécrire non
plus exactement donc on aurait pu penser
à des négociations avec le kremlin en
janvier qu'avec un meilleur succès de
genève avec un effort de la table de
négociations on aurait pu penser aux
sanctions plus
sérieuse avant l'invasion donc pour
prévenir plutôt que de punir tant que ça
pour s y aurait pu avoir des effets
escomptés et aussi je pense que c'est
très important maintenant comme c'est
très compréhensible on parle tous il
faut aider il faut battre il faut battre
deux côtés de l'ukraine mais est-ce
qu'on peut réfléchir un peu à ce qu'on
pourrait contribuer à la paix en ukraine
a plutôt qu'au combat donc pensé
communauté internationale efforts
onusiens
encore une fois les nations unies un
cessez le feu immédiat que la national
union pourrait imposer en ce moment ci
donc probablement ça c'est une piste de
réflexion plutôt que de s'investir dans
la logique de la guerre qui est imposé
par le kremlin en même temps faire des
grands l ukraine et frapper mais vous
nous en parler à l'émission plus tôt
cette semaine c'est tout l'ordre mondial
de l'après deuxième guerre qui
s'effondre maintenant comme si tout
était à recommencer fallait au 21ème
siècle qu'on n'a pas tiré les leçons du
20e non je suis d'accord avec ekaterina
on ne peut pas réécrire l'histoire en
revanche on peut identifier des causes
ou des facteurs qui ont contribué la
guerre qu'on connaît aujourd'hui est une
de ses co c'est certainement
l'affaiblissement de l'ordre
international
émergé après la chute du mur de berlin
qui était essentiellement basée sur
l'autorité des états unis auquel la
plupart des états disons se soumettait
d'une manière ou d'une autre et qui est
contesté depuis plusieurs années par la
russie et par la chine et il passe des
états unis plus faible face à des règles
que tout le monde commence à ne plus
véritablement suivre il ya des
situations comme celle qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui en ukraine et qui pourrait
se reproduire à d'autres endroits dans
le monde on a évidemment tous les
regards tournés vers taïwan et la chine
mais à d'autres endroits également cet
ordre international qu'on a connu au
cours des trois décennies je pense qu'on
peut dire qu'il est mort cette année en
2022 et ça ça veut dire elle confirme et
l'impuissance quad à la fois des nations
unies à la fois l'otan qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pour vous
savez déjà beaucoup de choses google ça
vous a beaucoup de choses regarder ce
qui s'est passé au conseil de sécurité
des nations unies passionnant à observer
les changes entre les diplomates bière
mais c'est un théâtre essentiellement
dont une nation unie sont paralysés
regarder ce qui va se passer en matière
de coopération internationale au cours
des prochaines années ça va être
extrêmement difficile et de manière
générale ce que poutine est en train
d'installer c'est l'idée selon laquelle
on peut briser toutes les règles du
droit international de la souveraineté
sans aucun prétexte et il n'y a
probablement pas de conséquence pourquoi
parce que l'autorité internationale mais
plus reconnue vous avez évoqué le
conseil de sécurité hier on a vu
l'ambassadeur des de l'ukraine sortir
son cellulaire je pense dire à
l'ambassadeur de la fédération de russie
a appelé à plus poutine qui disputent
dégager quelque chose ça ressemble un
peu à ça devient car elles n'ont bien 3
unis ouais ouais sur samassa évidemment
si on pense on pense toujours
l'analogie des années 30 lorsque en 38
on en parlait beaucoup l'invasion de la
pologne ça ressemble beaucoup à ce qui
arrive maintenant à 38 lorsque la
tchécoslovaquie été démantelés comme ça
laissez un peu parlé les puissances
occidentales pour pour la paix pour une
espèce d'illusion de la paix là
effectivement il y aussi à l'impensable
la radicalité du geste comme frédéric
gimet mentionné de une invasion comme
sur tout et imite sens en cause sans
provocation c'est dans un contexte aussi
il faut le rappeler où les institutions
démocratiques dans les pays dans nos
pays à commencer par les états unis en
europe il ya cette instabilité de plus
en plus g à l'intérieur deux de nos
démocraties et la l'instabilité
s'installe de plus en plus sur la scène
internationale avec l'exemple
d'aujourd'hui qui est qui aujourd'hui
diallo qui est très frappant lorsque ça
remet en cause encore une fois les
fondations de l'ordre poste deuxième
guerre mondiale fit complexe et qui sait
tout semble nous dire que c'est un
précédent contre le palais s'est pas
assez mal puisqu'on aura laissé son
effet rien et poutine été enfreint
toutes les règles de droit international
change l'ordre mondial c'est qu'on
n'était pas assez il veut revenir à un
monde bipolaire au fond avec je sais pas
si ça va être une polaire multipolaire
ça c'est sûr et certain que le monde
actuel ne lui convient plus ne lui
convenait jamais en fait à partir de du
secours de munich 2006 à peu près est-ce
qu'on peut le laisser passer mais
force est de constater qu'on est en
train de crier fort contre ce qui se
passe pour l'instant à l'ukraine sans
que cela ait des conséquences immédiates
quand on l à très court terme donc
j'appelle encore une fois à l'effort de
la communauté internationale à rétablir
la paix par tous les moyens possibles
l'ukraine n'a pas besoin de cette guerre
frédéric meyrals ou de nickel indé dû
rapidement être d'eric laisse que le
peuple ukrainien
devant poutine devant l'envahisseur
devant ce dictateur peut résister d'une
manière ou d'une autre mais là je pense
que denis carré les mieux placés pour
parler de ce qui se passe en ukraine
écoutez le
je parle à frédéric pendant la pause
dans la deuxième guerre mondiale est la
plus grande insurrection sur tout seul
européen contre c'est l instauration du
foie soviétique s'est fait en ukraine
ses fans du crâne de l'ouest
l'insurrection que 10 6 à 7 ans qui
était réprimée avec très grande
brutalité par le pouvoir soviétique mais
c'est tout de même se montrer la force
de résistance ukrainienne alors ça il
faut pas les minimiser quand j'ai évoqué
le spectre terrible d'une partition
c'est justement les régions de
l'insurrection qui resteraient libres
poutine actuellement
tous les pouvoirs tous les pouvoirs y
est d'ailleurs plus de pouvoir que tous
les secrétaires généraux du parti
communiste d'union soviétique qui l'ont
précédé jusqu'à jusqu'à staline et c'est
ça qui est extrêmement dangereuse c'est
un cul de balises pour
le contrer mais ceci dit personne est
parfait alors
les résultats peuvent être en fait très
imprévisible même pour lui alors je vous
revenir tous les trois pour une
conclusion rapide mais pour le moment je
vais joindre je posais prononce bien à
lviv en ukraine dans l'ouest du pays un
ancien ambassadeur du canada monsieur
workshop qui qui qui est avec nous en
pleine nuit je voulais simplement de
votre part une évaluation de la
situation il le choc que vous avez
ressenti aujourd'hui
chez vous
absolument
c'était
pire que prévu par beaucoup des
ukrainiens à mais ils ont des forces
armées qui est sont nettement meilleure
qu'en 2014 en partie pas grâce à anet
d'entraînement aussi du canada et ils se
sont battus à s'est farouchement un
surtout dans le nord et dans l'est
hier et ce soir alors qu'ils le sont pas
ils ont pas battus et crayons en effet
une espèce de légende de résistance au
mans en même temps le président monsieur
le secrétaire d'état a déclaré ya qu il
ya une heure à peine leur que dans le
fond poutine voulait renverser le régime
ukrainien le président céline ski qui
lui s'est déclaré très seul aujourd'hui
kiev qu'est ce qu'on aurait pu faire
autrement selon vous
je pense que
éliminer la possibilité de l'ambiguïté
en conservant une
participation militaire quelconque
hassan libérer les mains pour monsieur
poutine et vie jeudi comme l'attitude
américaine occidentales envers de taïwan
qui est une question liée à un
directement où il ya de l'ambiguïté 1 en
disant il n'y a rien à faire sauf les
cinq sanctions
ça donne cette solitude que monsieur
allen ce qu'il ressent ouais en même
temps comment voyez-vous les prochains
jours
je vois que c'est plus compliqué pour
les russes que prévu et
les questions est ce qu'il vaut ils vont
être encore plus brutal ce qu'on va voir
une escalade encore plus problématique
ou est-ce que même le petit mouvement
anti-guerre convoi en russie va prendre
l'emploi ouais mais en même temps est-ce
que vous craignez les conséquences d'une
défaite de l'ukraine
j'ai ramé mais c'est loin d'être
inévitable
à la force militaire
oui et la dinde et déjà mention du
peuple
ce que poutine à faire en niant
l'existence même du peuple ukrainien
ça a re motiver
et l'armée et la population est ce que
vous allez rester en ukraine
je
vais
regarder mes employeurs m'indique que
cherchez un emploi plus à l'ouest c'est
une bonne idée à tout moment mais je
reste en contact
avec mon équipe ici et on va soutenir
les grilles merci beaucoup monsieur
watts chacun d'avoir peu de temps à
parler en pleine nuit tour de table avec
vous et maintenant puisque nous va
chacun 20 secondes à peu près pour
conclure que votre chance cherchons nos
erreurs essayons de les corriger surtout
nous le répétons penser à quoi je vais
chez le plus en seconde
mais suivent à chaud qu
évoquer la résistance le dollar mais ce
qui est pas arrivé aujourd'hui justement
ceux des divisions de l'armée
ukrainienne qui sont rendus alors c'est
les ukrainiens se bat et peut-être que
poutine s'y attendait pas alarmer
général pour vous on ne peut pas exclure
un enlisement de la russie en ukraine
c'est un énorme pays de 40 millions
d'habitants et si il ya un enlisement
les occidentaux les alliés seront
impliqués d'une manière ou d'une autre à
commun
par exemple en fournitures d'armes en
relation et donc ça va rester un deux
aussi chaud pour très longtemps et en
même temps me dis que j'aime petites
minutes en réserve
est-ce que vous gardez espoir pour
zelensky
pour sa vie oui mais si jamais acquis et
retombe et le nouveau régime est et est
établie il faut attendre le calcul de
vladimir poutine qui peut trouver plus
rationnelle de le laisser vivre
me serais d'accord avec ça second jeu
disons un peu plus que si mu sur
l'avenir des élites ukrainienne si
jamais il tombe aux mains des forces de
sécurité russes tous les trois merci
d'avoir passé deux heures avec nous vous
étiez fort
éclairant pertinents merci beaucoup
gardent espoir pour l'ukraine merci
voilà madame messieurs c'est tout pour
ce soir le téléjournal sua l'instant je
vous donne rendez vous demain à 19
heures merci de votre attention
si céline galipeau
les bombes les morts des milliers de
déplacés l'ukraine peut-elle résister
longtemps à l'offensive de vladimir
poutine ce soir route et les gens
ou pignatelli chez au premier dîner
pizza les
[Musique]
véhicules de tourisme
y est vide est pour vous ai-je de gauche
il a décidé de porter la teinte la plus
grave à la paix dans notre europe depuis
des décennies
on impose d'autres sanctions sévères
[Musique]
la ville que j'aime sera détruit
je suis la seule
je me sens faible
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames messieurs le monde
retient son souffle alors que la russie
poursuit son offensive en ukraine pour
l'instant ce soir le bilan reste
incertain
l'ukraine parle de 137 mort de centaines
de blessés des informations qui ne sont
pas confirmées de nombreuses villes
importantes ont été bombardés dont la
capitale kiev qui reste en état d'
alerte cette nuit les soldats sont aussi
entrés par le bélarus au nord par la
crimée au sud et par l'est du pays
les russes disent avoir détruit de
nombreuses bases aériennes et des
installations militaires et ils ont pris
le contrôle de la centrale de tchernobyl
qui a été souvenez-vous le théâtre de la
pire tragédie nucléaire de l'histoire
déjà cent mille ukrainiens auraient
quitté leurs foyers des milliers
d'autres ont trouvé refuge déjà dans les
pays voisins l'invasion entraîné
l'annoncent d'autres sanctions contre la
russie aujourd'hui on va y revenir mais
d'abord retrouvons marie-eve qui est
toujours à kiev marie-eve le président
volodymyr zelensky a annoncé la
mobilisation militaire général pour
contrer cette invasion russe
ce que ça veut dire cette mobilisation
militaire général essentiellement c'est
qu'on rappelle tous les réservistes ce
qui était encore à attendre leurs ordres
de déploiement ça veut aussi dire alors
que beaucoup cherchent à fuir le pays
que les hommes de 16 à 60 ans ne peuvent
plus quitter le territoire parce qu'ils
pourraient être appelés à combattre on a
commencé aujourd'hui à distribuer des
armes aussi partout au pays à ceux qui
souhaitent procurer ces armes pour
l'instant cette mobilisation générale
n'affecte pas les femmes en janvier six
lignes le gouvernement avait changé la
loi pour permettre la mobilisation aussi
de femmes pas nécessairement dans des
rôles de combat mais pour l'instant
cette mobilisation ne semble pas les
toucher le président vladimir zemlinsky
qui s'est adressé à plusieurs reprises
aux ukrainiens aujourd'hui sa dernière
vidéo enregistrée dans un endroit qu'on
ne connaît pas elle lui a permis de
rassurer les ukrainiens mais aussi de
rendre hommage à tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui ont donné leur vie pour
tenter de repousser les attaques de la
russie les ukrainiens qui résiste mieux
que certains auraient pu penser dans les
combats au sol en tout cas ce n'est pas
une défaite totale l'armée ukrainienne
ne s'écroule pas mais l'armée russe a le
dessus du pavé pour l'espace aérien
c'est pour dire que les cibles qui ont
été visés au cours de la nuit dernière
et de la journée se sont beaucoup
intéressés au système de défense aérien
des ukrainiens mais il avance il se
dirige vers kiev volodymyr et linz qui
s'est montré impatient par rapport à la
communauté internationale il a dit avoir
contacté 27 dirigeants leur demandant à
tous s'il était possible que le
l'ukraine puisse rejoindre l'otan et il
n'a eu pour réponse que le silence
ils ont tous peur at il dit en lait
coûte rien d'où son nom d ici aux à
christine assez d'argent quant au retour
y voyez-vous raté à la zone va
chez sema n'est pas tout à fait tord
autorise daté au grain et radio scoop ou
d'or na
waie on le sent assez inquiet c'est plus
calme à kiev qu'à par ailleurs hier
quand on s'est parlé marie-eve mais on
s'attend on craint en tout cas que les
bombardements reprennent là sur kiev
c'est un calme très anormal très
angoissant on a annoncé de plusieurs
sources une reprise des bombardements
sur plusieurs cibles des ministères la
présidence le parlement pour le courant
de la nuit en fait à peu près au moment
où on se parle donc la plupart des
ukrainiens des gens à kiev mais ailleurs
au pays aussi passent la nuit dans des
bunkers les stations de métro sont
restées ouvertes pour héberger tous ces
gens qui n'ont pas de sous sol où se
prémunir de ces éventuels bombardements
les rues sont désertes qu'il faut dire
qu'un couvre-feu qui a été imposée à
partir de 22 heures et jusqu'à 7 heures
demain matin mais on s'attend une
relance donc de l'offensive de
l'aviation russe on a vu qu'elles ont
entendu quelques avions circuler dans le
ciel mais pour l'instant cette attaque
redoutée ne s'est pas encore produite
mais l' angoisse on la sent très très
bien on la lit sur le visage les gens
qui attendent le pire et 7 se prémunir
ceux qui ne sont pas parties encore et
on le comprend un petit mois encore sur
monsieur zelensky marie-eve qui craint
d'être l'acier blanc de la russie
c'est ce qu'il a dit dans sa dernière
adresse il a dit qu'il était la cible
numéro 1 il a dit aussi qu'ils avaient
des informations voulant que des
saboteurs soit déjà présent dans la
ville de kiev mais qu'il n'avait
l'intention d'aller nulle part lui et sa
famille sont toujours ici il va rester
au pouvoir il veut rester aux commandes
at-il voilà marie-eve merci beaucoup
d'être là en direct avec nous pour nous
informer merci
au revoir
alors voilà ce qu'on peut dire sur la
situation en ce moment même à kiev mais
on va revenir sur les dernières 24
heures qui ont été marie-eve le disait
la très éprouvante pour les ukrainiens
on va le faire avec sophie langlois
est érigée au présidial et voyons mené à
terrats
l'impensable est arrivé après dix
semaines de menaces le président russe a
déclaré la guerre à 5h50 du matin heure
de moscou 40 minutes plus tard les
premiers obus sont lancés sur la
capitale ukrainienne
brutal pour les habitants de kiev le
bruit des sirènes cristallise les pires
craintes moscou affirme ciblé des
installations militaires mais des obus
frappe aussi des civils surtout en
banlieue de la capitale jusqu'ici
plusieurs autres villes sont attaqués au
même moment kharkiv dans l'est de
l'ukraine et lourdement bombardé les
victimes sont nombreuses
[Musique]
les citoyens se réfugient dans les
stations de métro
ma femme dit il a appelé pour dire
qu'ils avaient commencé à nous bombarder
l'armée dit qu'on doit tous se
rassembler dans le métro
si l' invasion russe était prévisible
l'ampleur de la son surprend les russes
attaque l'ukraine par le ciel la terre
et la mer au sol les troupes de poutine
ont envahi le territoire à l'est mais
aussi au nord par la biélorussie et au
sud par la crimée et au dessin ou une
vingtaine de civils ont été tués les
blessés se comptent déjà par centaines
il ya une campagne de mort je tends
liane col d'agnes dommage tant
l'appétit site l'associé de sauvetage
ils me disent allez steve tran van
williams à
chicago
utilisent tous nous nous
et on avait hâte facebook loïse alicia
ko puisqu il est aussi victime le jour
non suite pour le président zelensky les
russes envahissent l'ukraine comme les
nazis l'ont fait il y à 80 ans et comme
dans toutes les guerres les citoyens fui
les bombardements
la ville de butch à près de l'aéroport
militaire en banlieue de kiev si
littéralement vidés
[Musique]
ceux qui en ont les moyens prennent le
chemin de l'exil
les autoroutes des gares et des postes
frontières ont été pris d'assaut ce
couple vient d'arriver en pologne lycée
la prime de crise qui a vu six telekurs
c'est cruel et violent city ça ne
devrait pas arriver au 21e siècle
a very sad j'ai très très peur d'italie
je suis triste j'espère que l'europe de
l'ouest et l'amérique vont nous aider ce
n'est pas juste d'être vertueux
ici sophie langlois radio canada
montréal
difficile je vous retrouve tamarins du
côté russe vladimir poutine a de nouveau
justifié l'intervention un mal
nécessaire at il dit pour sauver les
russes alors vous avez pu en parler
autour de vous est ce que les russes à
qui vous avez parlé ecall la cautionne
cette guerre
non pas du tout mais ça n'a pas
d'importance ici ce que la population
veut ou cautionne ou cautionne pas la
lumière poutine impose à la population
depuis presque 22 ans une culture de la
peur une culture selon laquelle les
l'occident
veut s'en prendre à la russie et que
l'ukraine est devenue la marionnette de
l'occident et les soldats les jeunes
hommes qui se battent et qui lance les
banques qu'on entend dans les reportages
que vous présentez sont le produit de
cette culture donc il ya des gens en
russie qui sont fiers de les voir à
l'oeuvre qui regardent la télévision
parce que c'est ce qu'on leur présente
qui voit la russie triompher et qui
coûtent les bilans quotidiens vous savez
ici ministère de la défense a dit en
cette première journée de guerre on a
accompli nos objectifs on a détruit 74
installations militaires plusieurs
aérodrome parce qu'on dit encore
heureuse que le seul but de cette
mission c'est de neutraliser du point de
vue militaire l'ukraine mais russe la
grande majorité ne sont pas dupes et ils
savent très bien que là n'est pas la
question et je pense qu'on avait
seulement à regarder dans les rues d'une
vingtaine de villes russes aujourd'hui
des gens qui ont pris le risque d'aller
manifester parce que aussitôt sortie
dans la rue aussitôt arrêté mais ils
l'ont fait ne serait-ce que pour prendre
quelques heures pour dire d'abord aux
ukrainiens mais aussi au reste du monde
que le régime n'est pas le peuple et
qu'il ne cautionne pas cette guerre et
cette agression sont horrifiés donc je
vous laisse entendre le témoignage de
deux personnes qui représentent bien ces
deux extrêmes
ce
qui
nous
[Musique]
gêne yannick agnel nous
sommes choqués
matthew robison être à ce
prix
du panier
ouais une guerre dont on ne connaît pas
l'objectif encore tamara et si c'est
encore possible de l'arrêter ou pas
non et il ya eu des tentatives
aujourd'hui étonnamment on a appris que
le président français avait téléphoné à
vladimir poutine qui lui a parlé pour
essayer de le raisonner on ne sait pas
s'il l'a fait au nom de l'otan ou si
c'était une initiative personnelle mais
aussi que ça n'a absolument rien donné
la dîmière poutine lui aurait encore
expliqué de façon exhaustive pourquoi il
a nécessité de cette guerre de cette
agression il a servi exactement le même
discours à des gens d'affaires au
kremlin aujourd'hui que le réunis et
qu'ils ont à diffuser encore le tout
comme une mise en scène à la télévision
les gens d'affaires qui se prépare aux
sanctions et à qui il a dit c'était une
question de vie ou de mort donc la
question combien de temps cette élite
qui est très importante pour vladimir
poutine est prête à subir les
contrecoups vous savez le rouble atteint
un plancher historique
il ya des pays qui songe à fermer la
porte aux citoyens russes tout court la
compagnie aeroflot est bannie bientôt du
royaume uni donc pendant combien de
temps les gens vont pouvoir accepter ça
c'est un des facteurs qui va falloir
surveiller il va falloir surveiller ça
mais les manifestations dont vous parlez
elles ont été très durement réprimées et
très rapidement réprimée à il ya eu une
très bonne relation est très nombreuses
arrestations voilà merci beaucoup tamara
vous aussi de de nous informer comme ça
on a l'impression d'y être un peu avec
vous merci
et à plus tard
et yasmine pour essayer de comprendre
davantage les enjeux de ce conflit
on va revenir un petit peu sur les le
rapport de force en fait entre l'ukraine
et la russie il ya vraiment un décalage
entre les deux armées oui clairement il
ya un déséquilibre céline il faut savoir
que la russie est elle se place au
deuxième rang des puissances militaires
hors nucléaire dans le monde alors que
l'ukraine et tour 25e rang les forces
russes sont estimés à un million 14000
soldat on parle de 209 mille soldats
ukrainien et là évidemment on ne parle
pas des réservistes qui risque d'être
mobilisés et les re sur le terrain ils
sont appuyés par des équipements
conséquent par des blindés par des chars
et on va voir clairement où se situe ce
déséquilibre des forces 18 fois plus de
lanceurs de missiles sol air pour la
russie en comparaison avec l'ukraine il
y a également cinq fois plus de
véhicules blindés chez les russes que
chez les ukrainiens
pour ce qui est de la marine c'est clair
51 sous marins russes 0 sous marins pour
les ukrainiens et pour ce qui est des
navires de combat il ya trente deux fois
plus de marine maintenant parlons de
l'armée de l'air le décalage est
flagrant dix fois plus d'avions et 18
fois plus d'hélicoptères entre la russie
et l'ukraine et vous le savez la défense
aérienne ukrainienne est faible et la
russie peut frapper partout sont des
chiffres tellement en frappant est aussi
la menace nucléaire là les russes
disposent bien sûr de l'art nucléaire
oui exactement ils disposent de missiles
de moyenne ou de portée intermédiaire
mais également de porter 30
transcontinental qui peuvent atteindre
10 millions une cible à dix mille
kilomètres alors que l'ukraine dispose
plus d'armes militaires après
l'éclatement de l'urss alors la russie
c'est la première puissance mondiale
nucléaire avec
6255 ogives en deuxième position
arrivent les états unis 5 1550 ogives
nucléaires et ces deux pays concentrent
80 2% de l'arsenal nucléaire mondial les
chiffres et à garder en tête la quand on
regarde ce conflit merci beaucoup
yasmine sans prix
et je poursuis avec juste un massicot
directeur du réseau d'analystes raté
j'ai professeur à l'université du québec
à montréal bonsoir monsieur vinci
alors quand on regarde les chiffres là
que yasmin vient nous montrer on réalise
à quel point c'est david contre goliath
même si marie-eve nous disait quand même
que les ukrainiens semblent bien
résister jusqu'à présent à l'offensive
russe mais combien de temps peuvent-ils
tenir
voilà la résistance et au sol
essentiellement faut comprendre un peu
la stratégie reut c'est à dire qu'ils
ont commencé avec une pluie de missiles
donc environ 160 là qu'ils ont été
busy donc l'ukraine pour détruire
essentiellement système de défense
anti-aérien ses avions des cours
militaires et progressivement tenter
d'apporter des troupes au sol un peu
plus proche de capital ils ont commencé
à circuler plusieurs villes ils ont
tenté prendre aéroport près de la
capitale de kiev ils ont échoué pour
l'instant ils vont tenter de reprendre
demain assure humains pour pouvoir
aéroporté des blindés des chars d'assaut
dans la région pour pouvoir
essentiellement en certes et la ville
pour faire pression pour parc activé le
gouvernement oui donc c'est ça
l'objectif faire capituler le
gouvernement remplacé le gouvernement
voilà et poser un gouvernement pro je
sais certains à l'instar ont le plus de
ce qu'on peut le voir la biélorussie un
gouvernement dit indépendant mais ça
c'est moi qui sera la solde de moscou ah
c'est l'objectif avoué par vladimir
poutine l'idée de contrôler et l'ukraine
pour qu'elles n'imposent pas une menace
entre guillemets choisissent toujours à
pour la russie car grand pour ces pages
jaunes auparavant c'est bien là son
objectif c est ce qu est ce qu il
pourrait aller plus loin parce que il ya
des craintes de ce côté là qu'en fait
les débordements contrôle et l'ukraine
oui mais même au delà des frontières de
l'ue craignent c'est ce que c'est
envisageable
c'est toujours possible une guerre il ya
toujours des bévues dans une bonne bière
toujours des tableaux cela dit il faut
faire quand même la distinction entre
les craintes des pommes de levain et six
voisins qui le sont et ce à des
américains ont en quelque sorte permis
l'invasion dans la mesure où ils ont dit
qu'ils n'étaient pas pour se porter à la
défense des ukrainiens solide et toute
une autre chose si les états unis
s'étaient portés à la défense de
l'ukraine mais ne l'ont pas fait et ils
ont par contre le président wade n'a été
très clair et les autres membres de
l'otan qu'ils vont défendre chaque
centimètre du territoire des membres de
l'otan dont qui sont en périphérie donc
à l'ouest et au nord de l'ukraine donc
je ne m'attends pas à ce qu'une escalade
dans cette mesure parce que le dire que
ce n'est quand même pas complètement fou
il veut pas faire la gare aux états unis
au reste de l'otan doit vouloir la
contenir sur les dix qui est possible
avec la fourniture si on tente de
conduire pour nous fournir des armes où
je craignais dans la résistance ou si
haut si on dise que de la magie de
possibles frappes sidère des attaques
ciblées contre les infrastructures
russes mais là il y aura possiblement
matière escalade possible possible donc
représailles rouste contre les états
unis contre d'autres pays qui
fournissent des armes tentent de venir
en aide aux résistants le craignait oui
alors bien sûr cette offensive elle
vient de commencer mais si l'ukraine
retombait sous le contrôle de la russie
qu'est ce que cela voudrait dire bon ca
de sas rêve ce serait plus un pays
démocratique qu'est ce que ça
signifierait pour l'europe pour le
canada les etats-unis
c'est vraiment un nouvel ordre mondial
dans lequel on se retrouve présentement
on voit vraiment ici au pacte de
non-agression avec la chine et la russie
qui cautionnent essentiellement cette
agression est une espèce de nouveau le
muraille qui va séparer l'est et l'ouest
ça sera vraiment un ordre ou qui a été
permis par cette
déclaration peut dire de l'hégémonie
américaine dans la région c'est à dire
qu'ils ne vont pas défendre l'ukraine et
se retrouver avec deux cas un quart
occidentale dirigée par les états unis
avec le soutien des européens et de
l'autre la russie qui montre qu'il n'y a
pas de règles du droit international qui
s'applique à elle et qui est soutenu par
une des plus grandes puissances
économiques la chine qui va permettre
d'ailleurs d'alléger un peu les
sanctions économiques ou le poids des
sanctions économiques sont imposées par
l'occident contre la russie donc dans
cette maison c'est vraiment une division
du monde à laquelle qu'on insiste je
vois la chine qui pourrait aussi
regarder attentivement ce qui se passe
en ukraine parce qu'évidemment elle a
ses intérêts à taiwan
et d'en tirer des leçons cela dit bien
sûr on peut voir que l'intérêt
géostratégique de taiwan est beaucoup
plus grave washington que neil et kiev
et l'ukraine je ne crois pas qu'on peut
penser là que les chinois voudraient
prendre avantage de la situation qui se
présente en ukraine pour tenter une
offensive contre roanne n'est pas
réaliste les américains ont fait une
démonstration de force des maritimes à
ses portes mais sa main pour monter
qu'il était sérieux dans leur défense du
de la mer de chine et aussi du
territoire de taiwanais et donc je crois
que l'on peut quand même être
relativement optimiste à cet égard la
queue il y aura pas à mon sens dans une
tentative opportuniste de la chute de
saisir l'occasion alors pour le moment
dans l'occident
garde mais laisse faire ce qui se passe
en ukraine alors on va suivre ça merci
beaucoup monsieur m'a ces jeunes non
plus
[Musique]
après la pause un tollé international
les pays occidentaux lance quand même
une nouvelle série de sanctions
et plus tard une attaque qui crée une
onde de choc la diaspora d'ici et
d'ailleurs démontre son soutien à
l'ukraine
[Musique]
cette invasion russe soulève un tollé
dans les pays occidentaux qui ont
annoncé une nouvelle série de sanctions
contre moscou le canada tout comme ses
alliés vise le portefeuille russe et
ouvre la porte aux ukrainiens qui
voudraient quitter le pays or de
nombreux canadiens en ukraine qui
aimeraient partir semble résigné à leur
sort christian noël
l'attak est justifiable de la russie
contre l'ukraine est inacceptable
déterminé et résolu ottawa sort son
arsenal de sanctions économiques qui
vise une soixantaine d'entreprises
d'oligarques et deux ministres du
gouvernement poutine elles vont limiter
la capacité du président poutine à
continuer de financer cette invasion le
canada annule aussi tout permis
d'exportation vers la russie liées au
secteur de l'aérospatiale de la
technologie et des minéraux un impact de
700 millions de dollars par année notre
objectif c'est vraiment avec nos alliés
de d'affaiblir et de déstabiliser le
régime perd environ 1000 militaires
canadiens sont ou seront déployés dans
les pays voisins de l'ukraine pour des
missions de formation et de dissuasion
as non pas des missions pour le combat
la réponse du gouvernement trudeau
reçoit l'appui de toute la classe
politique canadienne en arrière pour
si le canada agit ainsi euros nets
succès pour les milliers de canadiens
qui vivent en ukraine le réveil a été
brutal
une explosion
un bang mikhaylo a fui kiev pour la
campagne avec sa femme et ses quatre
enfants j'ai peur que la vie que j'aime
sera détruit
brenden qui vit à deux pas du parlement
avec sa fille a choisi de rester pour le
moment
pour les canadiens qui veulent fuir le
gouvernement trudeau a négocié un droit
de passage vers la pologne la slovaquie
la hongrie la roumanie et la moldavie
certains se sentent quand même
impuissant
à londres où
je vais partir ou
pourquoi à l'âge de 51 ans je vais
commencer un autre de notre vie se
séparer health ottawa promet
d'accueillir d'urgence les réfugiés
craignait mais pour ceux qui sont encore
là-bas les bons mots et les sanctions
économiques sont insuffisants besoin de
l'aide militaire de l'otan devant une
puissance nucléaire qui a choisi de
bafouer les règles du jeu la communauté
internationale dont le canada semble
pour l'instant vouloir éviter une
réponse militaire ici christian noël
radio canada ottawa
et éviter une réponse militaire c'est un
peu la même chose aux états unis pascal
ou joe biden a répété qu'il n'a pas
l'intention d'envoyer des troupes en
ukraine oui voilà c'était la première
fois qu'il s'adressait au peuple
américain depuis le déclenchement de
cette guerre là il l'a martelé il le
fait plusieurs fois dans les derniers
jours mais encore une fois malgré le
contexte qui a changé les états unis
n'iront pas en guerre sur le territoire
ukrainien il est trop tenir on pas sur
le territoire toutefois il y a quand
même des ressources militaires qui
seront envoyés en europe plus
précisément en allemagne on parle de
7000 troupes supplémentaires c'est
vraiment justement une opération pour
aider à consolider les forces de l'otan
et joe biden encore une fois a livré un
plaidoyer
passionné à l'égard de l'otan ce qu'il a
dit c'était qu'il était il était
terminer à ce que toutes les ressources
des états unis puisse aider il sera mise
de l'avant plutôt pour défendre chaque
centimètre du territoire des pays
membres de l'otan oui mais les pays de
l'otan et on le sait l'ukraine ne fait
pas partie de l'otan et c'est là un peu
le problème donc le président a lui
aussi durci le ton en imposant de
nouvelles sanctions à la russie le fait
juste après l'annnonce de justin trudeau
oui avec un objectif très clair
notamment celui d'empêcher la russie de
faire partie d'une économie mondiale
alors comment on fait ça dans un premier
temps on a annoncé une nouvelle ronde de
sanction qu'ils allaient toucher encore
une fois les institutions le milieu
financier plutôt des institutions
bancaires ont été ajoutés à une liste
qui avait déjà été mis de l'avant mais
là on parle de deux banques très très
importante aussi et possibilités
dorénavant pour plusieurs entités
publiques et privées d'obtenir des
capitaux qu'est ce que ça représente
selon le département américain du trésor
ça toucherait environ 80% de tous les
actifs bancaires joe biden a aussi dit
vouloir réduire de moitié les
importations en technologies là russie
notamment pour empêcher les forces
armées russes et l'économie aussi de se
moderniser et le président américain
l'année ça va prendre du temps encore
avant de se faire ressentir mais
vladimir poutine sera éventuellement mis
dans une position très inconfortable
il souhaite aussi qu'ils soient d'une
certaine façon isolée de toutes parts on
écoute le président
beugré bien sucré on a notre cantine
marché du riz à conakry un style très
bon match lourde
pour mouvoir interne à son stage et nina
carnet racing en sucre ou listées aux
associations
diplomatique c'est plutôt au point mort
les relations etats-unis-russie pas de
discussions prévues en fait joe biden a
refusé justement de dire qu'il voulait
parler au président russe aussi les
états unis aujourd'hui ont expulsé le
numéro deux de l'ambassade de russie à
washington c'était en réponse à une
expulsion qui s'était produite la
semaine précédente à moscou d'un
diplomate américain oui vraiment une
guerre une nouvelle guerre froide merci
beaucoup pascal merci
[Musique]
des mots très forts aussi de boris
johnson qui annonce lui aussi des
mesures de représailles économiques les
plus importantes et les plus sévères à
la russie les banques russes des membres
du kremlin des oligarques et l'éclat
compagnie aérienne aeroflot sont
notamment visés l'union européenne va
pour sa part gelé des avoirs russes et
empêcher les banques russes d'accéder au
marché financier européen
pendant ce temps vladimir poutine a eu
une conversation téléphonique avec son
homologue français manuel macron qui a
réclamé l'arrêt immédiat des hostilités
il s'agissait du premier contact
téléphonique connu entre le président
russe et un dirigeant occidental depuis
le début de l'invasion
[Musique]
gérald évidemment tout ça crée beaucoup
de volatilité beaucoup de nervosité sur
les marchés le pétrole dépasse les 100
dollars le baril absolument on se
demande en ce moment quel sera le
véritable impact des sanctions sur
l'icône me reuze sur la capacité des
russes à poursuivre une croissance
économique normal il y aura des effets
négatifs c'est clair et on se demande
également on essaie de mesurer quel
serait l'effet sur l'économie mondiale
l'approvisionnement en gaz et en pétrole
faut se rappeler que 40% du gaz naturel
d'europe vient de russie 25 % du pétrole
d'europe vient de russie et le tiers de
l'approvisionnement gazier vers l'europe
passe par l'ukraine en provenance de
russie alors beaucoup de nervosité et
beaucoup d'incertitudes aujourd'hui le
prix du pétrole a atteint un nouveau
sommet à plus de 105 dollars en cours de
séance à londres en hausse de 8% avant
de redescendre à la fermeture à 99 $
parce que les américains sont prêts à
utiliser leurs réserves stratégiques
pour combler le manque à gagner
potentiel du pétrole russe par ailleurs
sur les marchés boursiers forte baisse
ce matin et fortes hausses en après midi
vous dire donc il y a énormément de
volatilité new york le nasdaq toronto
était en progression après la chute en
europe en début de journée et la chute
marquée bien sûr à moscou à la bourse de
moscou 38% avec des pertes pour gazprom
notamment qui est le producteur gazier
le plus important bien sûr de russie
espère bien qu'également la banque russe
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
prévoir une inflation encore plus forte
il est clair que un conflit qui perdure
des approvisionnements gaziers
pétroliers qui seraient ralentis
pourrait faire grimper le prix du
pétrole à 120 150 dollars il y aurait un
effet sur le prix de l'essence jusqu'à 1
$ 80 dollars 85 le livre est donc il y
aurait des pressions inflationnistes
mais un conflit important pourrait aussi
ralentir l'économie mondiale et donc on
pourrait entrer dans ce qu'on appelle la
stagflation qui veut dire stagnation de
la croissance économique mais inflation
en même temps qu'ils seraient
importantes aujourd'hui le pdg de la
caisse de dépôt en a par des essais avec
une hausse du prix du gaz naturel en
europe une hausse du prix du pétrole on
peut exacerber ces deux facteurs l'eau
dans la même direction l'inflation
continue la croissance se modère
davantage l'inflation c'est pas grave
tant que de la croissance est ce qu'on a
vécu en 2021 eu des bons résultats mais
c'est de l'inflation et plus de
croissance ce qui ne convenait on peut
plus délicate et quels sont les effets à
prévoir sur l'économie du canada peu
d'effet peut-être sur l'inflation mais
la russie n'est pas un partenaire très
important du canada cela dit les
producteurs de céréales de bli de
potasse de fertilisants pourrait
profiter d'un manque à gagner qui
viendraient de la russie les producteurs
canadiens pourraient en profiter et il
est plus réaliste de penser que le
pétrole canadien puisse remplacer le
pétrole russe sur le marché européen
notamment dites vous bien que les états
unis l'arabie saoudite pourrait combler
une partie du manque à gagner potentiel
voilà alors on a appris un nouveau mot
grâce à vous aujourd'hui merci gerald au
revoir
ils attendent un puissant la suite du
conflit après la pause l'angoissent des
canadiens d'origine ukrainienne
et à venir comment en est on arrivé là
regard sur le passé de vladimir poutine
[Musique]
le prix n'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est le vaccin une question de survie
qui sera le premier c'est ici que les
premières souches de sarm skov de ont
été isolés entre compétition et repli
sur soi les gouvernants doivent vacciner
leur population d'abord la distribution
du vaccin est inégale dans moon
l'égoïsme des grandes puissances à
nouveau entre nouvelles alliances et
anciennes rivalités et à ce moment là
que nous avons contacté les bus la
serbie a été l'un des premiers pays avec
de telles relations avec la chine la
diplomatie du vaccin en grand reportage
mardi 20h icr ni familiprix coupe ses
prix pour la famille livange cette
semaine obtenez le papier hygiénique
mais j'y suis tous essentiels à 4
dollars 97 ou des produits de coloration
l'oréal paris 9 dollars 97 la famille
vivante seulement chez familiprix on a
réussi à remplacer les muscles des
jambes de sa barre par ceux d'un cheval
de course et le futur sur ses futures
j'ai économisé grand comme une âme en
assurance habitation et auto en ligne
avec sonné cinq petites minutes grosses
économies assurez-vous en ligne sur ce
n'est point ca
[Musique]
familiprix coupe ses prix pour la
famille des ventes cette semaine obtenez
les produits tda sélectionné à 16
dollars 97 ou les produits listerine à 5
dollars 90 cents
seulement j'ai pu me libérer découvrez
leur réalité dans sportive point final
l'émission et balado de radio canada
sports
le sous-titrage cette émission vous est
présenté par fidelity investments vous
travaillez fort pour prendre les devants
informez-vous sur fidelity pour vous
aider à rester à l'avant garde
[Musique]
on évoquait plutôt la russie mais des
manifestations ont eu lieu un peu
partout dans le monde aujourd'hui pour
dénoncer l'invasion en ukraine cette
solidarité on l'a vu aussi au canada
aujourd'hui le pays qui abrite la
troisième population ukrainienne en
importance dans le monde mais ce que
l'on sent surtout chez eux c'est l'
angoisse pour leurs proches pour leur
pays voici le reportage de matthieu
papillon
c'est mon ami qui venions
au canada de la doll aussi qui m'a
enlevé à minuit comme pour bien 18
régnait la nuit de vitaly stoyan a été
courte pour lui impossible de fermer
l'oeil devant le début d'une attaque
tant redoutée ma mère
d'explosion à ses drops
[Musique]
parce qu'il a beau avoir déménagé au
canada il ya près de 20 ans l'ukraine
reste son pays celui où toute sa famille
habite encore moi je suis là ce
jeu très inquiète et a de ma famille de
mes parents
les sentiments partagés parmi
l'importante communauté ukrainienne du
canada qui regroupe un million trois
cent mille personnes plusieurs se sont
d'ailleurs mobilisés aujourd'hui un peu
partout au pays
si le choc est aussi grand c'est que le
conflit a souvent quelque chose d'un
team pour les manifestants mettant là
sont là bas ma mère dé mais il va avoir
quatre ou cinq ans elle doit préparer sa
valise il partir ça ne peut pas se
passer en 2022 pour cet autre
montréalais l'occident ne va pas assez
loin dans sa réponse à l'offensive des
rues si les mêmes sanctions économiques
etc et pas de pas qu'ils vont vraiment
parler ce langage de poutine qui lui ne
parle pas en terme économique c'est un
dictateur il n'écoute que la langue de
la force à toronto la foule a pu compter
sur l'appui de cette jeune femme
d'origine russe
[Musique]
bryan stow faux
britt reid
lâché
pendant ce temps vitaly stoyan suit les